people
we were just deciding if we should start
the show in Spanish but that's all I
know
so to the point hey
[Applause]
Trace podcast
no notes wow
yeah I love the way that the um the
Spanish like hosts do that they go Bueno
they say it was such a passion yeah
is so good
it's a sunny day out here in Los Angeles
people
yeah we're back it's uh it feels like
Monday but it's not at all is it it's
Wednesday
it is Wednesday it's all surround
let's see
oh no
so sad
[Music]
oh
did that say 300
[Applause]
300 pounds in your foot round bars
welcome everybody it's off the rails
happy to be here
with all you guys
and all you guys it's a privilege to sit
here and uh share this time together
thank you to our sponsor gamer Subs uh
I'm starting to hear reviews from people
who have gotten their Sigma brain
hearing really good things good feedback
really good things let's go because
listen you know this flavor is off the
rail y'all got to try it we got our own
flavor Sigma brain it's spicy Margarita
flavor
hmm
I think we did it I think we
masterminded the ultimate flavor
Sigma brain
from gamer sub lead free
I thought I sat down I said no lead they
said we don't have lead
is it perfect
more on that later
um
we have a gajillion things to talk about
because we missed
we were gone on Monday because of Labor
Day thank you to our dear laborers
you're very you're so welcome thank you
you're welcome
I saw some discourse
about Labor Day and of course something
that's all considered uh all
occurred to us the most
labor-ish laborers do not get that day
off very true
show up at work and work hard you know
what I mean like when I was in a
Hospitality waiting restaurants you
ain't never getting that day off oh no
oh no
Labor Day
get your ass up and work
um so so there you go we took the day
off and we loved that for them
and and thank you to the laborers
especially those who had the work
first of all to enjoy our beautiful
Monday holiday
I bet you the CEOs go again Labor Day
Off
hell yeah the hardest workers in the
company
very interesting
I bet you uh nobody labors harder what's
the Disney guy's name the CEO Baba I bet
auger won working on no damn Mondays
Labor Day
mm-hmm
you better be Pinocchio to salvage his
woke trash company true
um
uh but yes so then we missed yesterday I
was live for members thank you to you
guys and we're back today
um
giving it up and also I'll say this
there's no leftovers tomorrow either and
it's not my fault it's his son's fault
so what he's going on vacation you said
yeah he's going on vacation with his
family I was like are you serious that's
dude I said are you
dumb or something are you dumb this
would have been this would have been
like our fourth one I and you know what
this
is the best crop of that has
happened in a long time so what do we do
about material
I don't know what are we gonna do about
it gay and talk about some of it today
we already have so much so much maybe on
Friday Friday weekend sure because songs
like a pretty boy
okay tip what about me
okay I'll take these years I'll take it
yeah good enough
um
data says have you guys seen Charlie's
giant gamer sub claw machine what the
excuse me don't buy his flavors
flavor probably sucks
does he have a flavor I believe he does
probably tastes like
bro take my brain that's probably fine
probably not it's it's probably a
perfectly fine product but it's probably
called
he probably couldn't decide between you
know sweet or sour and he kind of just
sat on the fence
you gotta pick a lane that's fine
Charlie can't just sit on the fence with
the flavors people don't like Ethan and
that's totally fine shut up you
flavor sucks bro here it is uh Divine
Peach that's nasty sounds sexual I don't
know this is G fuel yo what the
fuel what are you sending this is
this not a GG claw machine it looks no
it totally is because those are the cups
I reckon you'll get that G fuel
out of here dude garbage that has
lead in it
a negligible amount apparently but any
lead is not good in my opinion
them dude gamer sup Nation so why
so does he not have one
I don't know you should know love what's
the deal I don't think so no oh well
then seen it what a loser he doesn't
even have a camera
loser idiot wow a loser I'm sorry but
y'all are never going back to any other
flavor once that Sigma brain hits your
lips
is there is there any reviews dropping
on it yet see my brain you just said you
heard no but I mean like officially
there's no official not yet
I heard really good things you guys
we've seen some on the sub yeah on the
side people who just got it yep well we
gotta get like
like our like review bra and those guys
on it review bra does he review uh gamer
flavors
now he does friend of the show
uh what else was I talking about but
basically
um Tomorrow there's a Teddy fresh drop
actually some really cool stuff
including this shirt which I freaking
love I've been waiting it's so simple
but it's so nice it's like um
Tim are you here
would you describe this material
describe the material yeah a waffle knit
maybe what is it like waffle knit yeah
dude it's so sick it's very cozy oh my
God and it just looks super nice here's
the thing this is an XL I think I'm
ready for the largest
podcast host in history I'm ready for
the largest tiny little guy I've
unfortunately lost a few pounds rather
quickly during the shredder stuff so
I'm down to like 186.
it's your birth no it's not your birth
here Mike mud so what oh no so my
original goal was 180 I'm getting very
close but I said a new goal to 170.
wow which I think would be considered a
very healthy way for a person of my
step eyes and stature who stands tall at
5 11.
this is so good I can't stop sipping it
sipping on the sub it takes him a second
to get on the stool because he's under
five feet tall
not me I'd sit right on that still quick
delete my browser history when I die I
thought that was good it's fun
you know what I mean it's fun and it
doesn't necessarily mean it could mean
anything you know what I mean
don't read too deep into it okay
just curious oh this is sick oh I'm
wearing that right now throw it off is
it fleece what is our like uh velor
velor velor
velor
this is a reissue of the classic and
gray tones everybody loves that sweater
this is some cool 3D uh Graphics okay
sick love that
a uh
Sherpa zip up
so cool thank you pants plaid these look
good
like that
oh we did the shirt as well shout out
delete my browser history and mesh
so you can show off your
delete
curves are you can't really see through
it eh delete
cool though cool sure we got it in hat
form
so you really want to let everybody know
please bro please
what is this Sam there's little things
on it it's like a little piercing I love
that detail it's really cute oh I've
never seen this on one of our hats
before looks like covid gotcha
thanks Dan
looks like open molecule
uh this is cool apparently
we got this sick ass zip up sweater
you know what I'm saying yeah oh this is
also a reach this was like the very
first shirt we ever made
reissued
that's cool I'm gonna want one of those
definitely
we got this
this is a classic just plaid zip up why
not I'm wearing that one you are let me
see
oh it's got a cool back oh currently
unavailable to care oh
let's go right now dude
four more images
this is a beautiful piece just classic
beautiful iconic
charts
long sleeves
and this classic iconic shirt it's a
little bit of a drop not a huge one but
a little something lots of fun stuff
there
tomorrow 10 a.m PST you know what it is
All Right Where Do We Begin
how's everybody been long last weekend
huh
you guys have a good time good Labor Day
anyone do anything interesting
all right Vanderpump
nothing just watching Vanderpump I beat
uh Baldur's Gate I did too so good
the ending kind of happened too fast
oh it's your balls in my mouth huh
okay
I'll let that one go
how did you so ultimately what's your
review
I mean it's 10 out of 10. I loved it I
mean I I am big into those kind of games
like RPGs and played D growing up and
everything and so for me it's it's spot
on I've moved on to uh armored Core
though which is
totally consumed me for most of the week
really is that fun yeah
it's pretty good I heard it's fun but
not like amazing game but fun
I think that's fair
I don't know if you're into those kind
of games I I think it's uh it's elite
level
so yeah I beat Baldur's Gate I agree it
was fun I mean a great game for sure I
moved on to Starfield which
I've been playing it on my steam deck
that's cool interesting it runs but man
it's it is like that thing is like a
runs hot and loud you know what I mean
but anyway it's pretty fun so far
um Coral said just sending this message
to say hi to my friend Stella I hope
architecture school is going well for
you
much love okay thank you missed
connection there
Stella Carol
is uh
saying hi
and we love that for her why am I so
springy today I don't know why the
lights are blinding me
just been away for too long you know
forgot how bright these things are my
mom is posting butterfly porn
you know she's out of control
but the monarchs are doing well so I I
don't blame her for being excited
but uh she is out of control there's no
question about it butterfly porn she
says and then she says in parentheses
all caps rare footage not clickbait
did she write this because yeah so
thousand percent sure I had no
involvements rare footage how did she
even know to do that
so here it is rare footage guys can we
show this on YouTube oh it's a little
spicy a little spicy I'm in my backyard
we came back here for the Labor Day
holiday eating and look what I've got
I've got two mon Elks having sex in my
backyard x-rated oh my God this is the
world you wanted Donna oh my God they
are mating that is too much
hold on hold on who's this guy standing
behind her that was my brother
wait no who is that
that's not my brother he's the cuckold
he likes to watch
is that guy
he likes to watch dude
do not know who this guy is
who are you dude there's a new mystery
unlocked my mom they don't hang out with
like interesting different people you
know what I mean hmm
this is her backyard this is her
backyard hmm neighbor an interesting
person
yeah it could be a boring person
neighbor I don't know it's the NPC
yeah well let's get this can we get some
romantic music going down yeah I got you
yeah go ahead
yeah Max having sucked in my backyard
edit monarchs look at this oh my God
they are mating yes ma'am this is the
world we want no I mean hello hello
mom who is this if you're watching the
is this he's so amused he loves it
look at that big smile
all right
hmm
explain this Mom
[Music]
got a lot of likes 5000 likes
it's good stuff people are supporting
her the pool by Chad is saying shut up
it's not the poor boy
um I actually know who
the pool man is he's a very nice guy
he's an older side and he looks nothing
like that gotcha gotcha there was a
heated debate actually during the break
spot uh sparked by
Sam's disgust
for something Ian does
[Music]
um
what else is new
oh Sam hmm is there is there trouble in
Paradise
Ian why aren't you tell him what you did
well here I'll play the video Sam that's
better right yeah that's better so you
guys we're gonna have to do a poll on
this and you all tell me what you think
about this okay it's very interesting
uh yeah let's just go ahead and unmute
it that'll be helpful
one more time okay I have a question for
all of you Scholars out there
oh okay that's not me
turn it off let's move on not for you
got him whenever I get to a hotel or an
Airbnb or whatever it is
even for just one night the moment I get
in there I immediately fold all my clubs
I hang them on the provided hangers in
the closet and I fold I put all of the
folded clothes in the dressers I really
move in even if it's for one night I
think it's organized Sam says that
that's cereal Serial Killer Dexter style
stuff literally like it's you're
probably your biggest red flag that's a
red flag to pack my clothes
are you serious yes it's weird I
have the ick for packing my clothes in
the hotel yes
what they put the hangers in there for a
reason they put
so there's clearly
a heated debate going on some agreeing
some disagreeing of the poster titled it
Sam is right this is psychotic behavior
so the the accusation Ian is that
you put all the away in the hotel
even if it's for one night yeah and
people act like that that's so crazy for
one night such a waste of time
I if I'm packing for one night there's
not a lot of my bag it's pretty easy
transfer yeah to me the the issue isn't
the time requirement
it's just like the settling in like why
are you settling in the way I see it is
I move it into the things and then my
empty bag that I traveled with I sort of
view it as like a dirty camper that's
not a bad so then I put my dirty clothes
into the bag and then I can kind of
separate okay those are dirty and the
clean ones are out of the bag that makes
sense aren't you gonna put all of your
clothes back in the bag to take them
home regardless though that is very
that's a great question and I've thought
of it I do a layer to separate the dirty
from the clean once I re-pack everything
back tomorrow right but the original
like source of problem why are you
nesting right like everything that's the
part yes somewhere I I would defend Ian
a little bit here why don't you do it a
lot I text you this when I saw the story
I say I think he's nuts however
if you have like a suit a sport coat
something that needs to be hung up I'd
feel like that's not what we're talking
about
I have questions so Ian how long have
you been doing this
um not forever it's a fairly new thing
but we talk about you you found him and
I would say within the last like I don't
know was I doing it when we first met
every trip I have ever been on with you
you do that what was your what was your
Awakening
well I sort of thought if I'm gonna be
in this room I should use everything I'm
really going to take advantage of what
they're doing I'm paying for this right
was it perhaps the first time that you
paid for a hotel rather than going on a
trip with your family or something and
you realize the expense it's like I want
to take advantage of these amenities no
I think maybe it was a longer trip and I
felt like my dirty clothes and my clean
clothes and it was all just floating
around the bag you know entropy was
occurring in the bag so I said I'm gonna
let's clean this up well listen I I I
think that there to me there's a
threshold there's a time period if
you're there and I don't know what it is
I'm not claiming to know what it is but
there is a certain point where you're
staying somewhere long enough that it
does make sense to do that one night is
kind of crazy and there's no time in my
opinion that makes to justifies that I'm
kind of no amount of time we're moving
where are you going for a like a rental
yeah what if you're going somewhere for
a couple weeks that's not enough
that's my only thing one day is a little
bit of time I mean I usually like a
month and plus we buy if you're not
there for a month you're leaving that
I honestly agree Ian they have bags for
dirty clothes in hotel rooms they do yep
that's true I don't have a bag already
it's like no no your bag to the grocery
store hold on I have more questions he
brings his bag to those yeah is this the
behavior that you've adopted for one of
your parents
uh no I don't know where this came from
wow that's crazy even crazier
Sam's shaking her head at me okay so we
went to an Airbnb over the weekend we
stayed for two nights I unpacked two
sets of clothes into the dresser and I
put a coat in the closet
felt good to me
[Laughter]
I like to hang my clothes because I want
them to be ironed or have them not be so
wrinkled up from being in my bag also
fair if you got certain shirts that you
hang up in the car rather than put in
the back and that's fine I don't agree
with that that's fine but putting the
stuff in the drawers is crazy yeah also
who knows what's going on in those
drawers yeah for real-time drawers are a
little like what's actually that was one
of the main sort of pushbacks I saw in
that thread was bed bugs and that sounds
to me like some sort of Hotel propaganda
to keep me you're probably right
dressers well listen if there's bed bugs
they'll be in your bed yeah your GGO bed
bugs yeah yeah whatever that is no the
Bible keeps the doors clean I know but
they're going to be in the bed if
they're in there they're going to be you
got the the Gideon's Bible who knows
what people do with that in the drawer
sticky pages in that Gideon's Bible yeah
toenails and it's bad there's a
little subtle verses in there you know
what I mean I got a lot of
Silent silence Court responding to me
who her as of right now they're not
brave enough to come out publicly you
know it's a Hot Topic but I've received
a lot of Silent support from people in
this room
not well Zach messaged me uh uh showed
support I I gave you a somewhat
supportive message I don't know if if
you got the message but I will tell you
that Ally backed you up she did yeah
now I'll say like theoretically I like
the idea of it I like the idea you put
it away you know where stuff is because
sometimes I'm on vacation it's hard to
find in your suitcase which is hard
there's just tons of you got to
move it around so I like the idea
theoretically however
I'm trying to find what I sent you did I
text it to you or or maybe I and you
responded on Instagram so
I feel like it also depends on the level
of Hotel you're at cabin okay maybe you
know you don't know who's been there but
if you're like at the Ritz Carlton go
for it
I may introduce more about the blasting
I may introduce a wipe to the drawer
before you did no I I think I will after
reading some feedback
you'll introduce a what a wipe a little
wipe down of the drawer oh interior oh
okay well then because now you're
introducing so much work now there's a
typing down activity
yeah yeah that feels weirder why what
are you concerned about in the drawer
I don't know you know did somebody
in theirs Blood come you don't know
somebody's just jacking off into the
yeah they do that yeah there were a lot
of commenters in this thread that kept
referring to like semen in the drawers I
don't know what our audience
the foot soldiers are up you never come
back the soldiers are on something you
never blasted into a hotel that's right
no yeah people people enter some weird
well also those even even less
weird putting other people have been
putting their dirty clothes in there
probably and I don't think Maids like
clean inside the drawer no I don't
stinky weird people putting their stinky
weird in there my stays in the
back here's what I wrote to you and I
said
listen
Sam caught said it's her ick where did
she say that in the video gee I didn't I
thought that was that was mean Sam that
was mean and herbal I appreciate you
backing me up I said to Ian not fair to
call it an ick though Sam should I said
it's Mom behavior is what I told Ian
however it's not fair to call it an ick
Sam should take that back
that is pretty far okay I won't not an
ick but it is serial killer and
it's weird
all right that's not as bad no that's
not that's not as bad as saying a ick
yeah because the ick is like what you
get when you're like I can't even I
can't I'm not even attracted to this
person anymore
no no yeah come on serial killer
cannibal freak
you gotta stop a hundred percent I do
believe that
um so I don't know I mean I I can see
both sides personally it's not something
I would ever do
and it is the fact that it's just Ian
doing it too makes it specifically funny
and uh interesting to me it doesn't
surprise me at all that a b does that
just because he's very organized yeah I
I will say though I don't put my boxers
or my socks in the drawers
I'm socks maybe but boxers I want
they'll stay in the suitcase yeah
but your shirts are folding up you're
putting those in there yeah yeah shirts
or shorts pants so basically let's throw
it to the audience I'm curious
I threw up the poll a couple minutes ago
and um is it a good pull this is a
horrible poll yeah for the meme I knew
this was going to be a bad poll even
when Dan said he already put it up
that's me
so is Ian's cycle for this now I have to
really think through this before I vote
[Music]
you know even though it's something I
would never do
[Music]
I'm gonna say no it's not psycho ah but
is it
it's the nesting it was one day Ian
you can't live out of your suitcase for
one day man
no I I've done it for one day when Sam
and I drove her car back from Georgia I
did do it in the hotels for one night
but that's not typical so you saw this
from the very beginning Sam
it's been a thing and actually not only
that you saw him at his worst in fact it
was one night first time he went to come
get you to move in and then you see Ian
putting his away for one night did
you have second thoughts in that moment
no I was just like huh
okay
no ick though I want to clarify there
was no ick yeah yeah I didn't hear a
Nick in there let me just clarify Ian
does not give me the egg
I have a question for you
we stayed in Lake Tahoe two nights
together but we stayed at two separate
locations did you pack and unpack and
then pack and unpack again at two
separate locations those two nights
yes I did all right
man that's psycho and how long have
you been doing this this is a new
development that you yourself decided to
engage in like in the last few years
right I think when I started to when you
could round up to 30 I felt a change in
my system
[Music]
well I I I'll be honest I ultimately I I
love you Ian I couldn't vote Yes I voted
no however I'm in the vast major a
minority here Jeffrey dahmers so can we
66 Ian said yes you're psycho for this I
want to can we ask how many people have
done this I'm curious probably uh 34 so
you think it's the same well they could
be like I'm I'm psycho too okay that's a
good question let's say have you done do
you do this yes sir no because I'm a no
but I also voted in support of Ian
do you
unpack
unpack immediately do you unpacks
regardless of time stayed regardless of
time stayed perfect I had no idea yeah
that's a good pull right yes very
specific yes I do no I do not
do you put Sam's Club way in
no I would I would never you know would
he would you be okay with him doing that
Sam I would not want all of my stuff put
away also keeping everything in one
location for me like everything is in my
bag it helps me make sure I'm not
leaving things behind yeah
because that would drive me crazy
having stuff everywhere so there's a
rogue with 15 percent
that although they do not do this they
said it is not psycho me being one of
them however 19 now says yes I have done
this so that is man it's one in five
it's fairly common well you know what
else people have one in five of
them
murder uh uh arthritis I don't know
there's a lot of stuff that people have
one in five and it makes them freaks I'm
sorry
getting all crazy right now
uh I so there it is Ian how do you feel
knowing everything knowing 19 19 of our
audience are on the right side of
History that's good to know that they're
out there
violently supporting we'll see when you
get meningitis or something from the
drawer
that's probably not possible
um let's see roughly 20 of the
population are estimated to be regular
smokers there you go there you go one in
five one in five people yeah you're like
you're you're you're a chain smoker one
in five people are are cool you know
just cool give me more one and five I
got you I want more stats so uh one in
five people usually exercise
regularly
yeah wow that's psychopath
only one working out is kind of psycho
yeah them holy I thought it
was more uh consume alcohol
one in five
like the regularly higher you mean like
is an alcoholic borderline it just says
consume alcohol what does that include
well well there's a lot of countries
uh one in five people have a tattoo
okay no but what about like what about
like I want diseases and bro yeah
let me see you know what I mean give me
the sad stuff yeah yeah so we have a we
go get a tattoo we have a drink we go
for a run yeah we put our dogs in the
closet and then you go and uh murder a
prostitute over a plastic tarp uh high
blood pressure is roughly around one in
five
blood pressure that's it I thought wheat
is all walking around with our hearts
about to explode uh globally
um
let's see obesity is around one in five
oh come on not where I live this is
worldwide ain't nowhere in America it's
like one it's like half isn't it like
one third
That's crazy dude
but okay all right thank you uh thank
you uh uh maybe actually speaking of um
one in five
I continued my lupus investigation
one in five people have Lupus well
there's some you know one and something
you know I don't know what it is right
so I saw the um
dermatologist that was my next goal
issued to me by my rheumatologist to get
a opinion on the rashes on my face right
uh you can see them they they come in
quite strongly because I stopped
treating it in preparation to see her no
so I had a pretty severe rash here no
yeah I can see here
at the corner of my eyes yeah under my
nose right here and so I said doc
positive a a
some inflammation
no how long do I have left to live
speckled
speckled homogeneous
and she looked at me
she looked at the rashes
and she said to me that's lupus
it looks like uh eczema your skin is
really dry
looks like eczema did she give you a
topical cream potentially also something
fungal those eggshells which is weird
fungal no fungus on your face bro I
thought that was odd okay I guess it's
almond I don't know yeah it's common
it's very cold so I have a I have a
anti-fungal cream and a steroid gel that
I put on one in the morning one at night
and I'm gonna do that for four weeks wow
man how are you gonna make it and then
we'll see
if the rash goes away
but uh both the rheumatologists
and the dermatologist and I don't know
I'm probably going to need another
opinion on this oh say that it's uh
probably eczema and not lupus yeah no
can you like get an appointment at the
Mayo Clinic or anything in a real like
I've already seen I mean I've seen UCLA
Medical Group senior Cedar Sinai only
Selena Gomez herself could be the one to
tell you but who does not have Lupus the
lupus Queen I have all the best doctors
in the world working around the club
to make sure you have Lupus
um so and then I'm gonna do I'm gonna
retest my blood in three months to keep
an eye on you know the tighter
keep an eye on the inflammation those
titers tight
and uh well it turns out that uh
you know I can't say for sure I don't
have Lupus we're not sure I mean you
never know they say it's the great
Pretender that's what they say about it
I'm sorry nine in ten people with lupus
are women
oh that's so interesting
hmm whoa nine and ten
man you're unlucky come to think of it
all the lupus people I know are all
women
what that's so weird don't women do deal
with enough man
someone says you're not supposed to put
steroid cream on your face daily well
I guess I'm gonna need to talk to
another dermatologist you better go tell
your doctor uh that this chatter said no
no don't do that it's every day for four
weeks
thank you
um that's so weird what diseases are
uniquely men other than prostate because
women don't have one
do men have that
uh have you checked if you have segma
I'm seeing the sigma specialist later
this week yeah it's not due to gluten I
got tested for all that I didn't
have any gluten antibodies biomarker
for sure
dude people keep going um
I think this is like a Hot Topic thing
the uh steroid withdrawal thing just
because people are seeing it on Tick
Tock now admittedly that does look
horrible and uh my heart goes out to
them but
guys you don't get addicted to steroids
from using a
a mild steroid for to treat one outbreak
everybody
everybody's a dermatologist
steratoid I never heard of that
until I was on Tick Tock then I see
these people with their skin all cracked
and up and they're like I'm
living in Thailand because it's more
moist here no
it's very sad actually I feel horrible
for them
it looks really bad but I don't think
that's how I don't think I'm gonna get
steroid uh withdrawal from using a
little cream for a couple weeks
thank you for your support though Sigma
is fatal make sure to take that uh
take that seriously
so funny
um could it be lupus okay thank you love
no worries good question we have a do we
have a check mark
could it be lupus this is our lupus quiz
okay okay get started yeah I thought I
thought well he already why are we doing
this we don't need well I don't know
that's just one question you've been
through this though I think this is
several times Medical Professional yes
I've talked to a hematologist a
rheumatologist a dermatologist
but I have not taken an online quiz okay
fair enough have you ever had pain or
swelling in your joints for the more
than three months never
gotta click next yes though do your
fingers become pale numb or comfortable
never not once
have you ever had sores in your mouth
that last for more than two weeks never
okay
have you ever been told that you have
low blood cell count actually I have
actually that's interesting they say
have you ever told you have low blood
cell count white low white blood cell or
low platelets actually the thing that
started this all was that I had elevated
uh oh so no platelets and white blood
cells right so the answer to this one
which was scarier because that was
suggestive of potentially some kind of
leukemia right that is scary we gotta do
the leukemia quiz right okay let's do
that one next okay I got you no I don't
I think that one for now
we're good on that my hematologist said
we don't need a bone marrow sample yet
what he said because they're laughing at
me
uh so obviously so that's gonna be a no
yeah yeah that's a no as well have you
ever had a noticeable rash on your
cheeks for more than a month so it's not
on my cheeks so no so no no so no okay
yeah does your skin break out after
you've been in the sun no I'm fine okay
cool great have you ever had has ever
been painful to take a deep breath for
more than a few days no that'd be really
work concerned that'd be scary have you
ever been told that you have protein in
your urine
um no okay that'd be a weird thing for
someone to tell you have you ever had
rapid hair loss what do you guys think
no okay and have you ever had a seizure
so my doctor does uh suspect that I
might have a mild form of epilepsy oh
which is why I have this problem with
falling asleep when I'm driving in the
car I don't actually fall asleep I get
super drowsy so I can't say yes
but maybe I do all right drum roll
please but I'm gonna say no let's see
are you female hmm
no okay
uh yes
it must be holy dude I'm gonna be
I'm so sorry are you Hispanic Latino
Spanish Cuban Mexican Puerto Rico South
Central American or Spanish
uh no okay
do you identify with any of these races
keep that drum roll going we're almost
there black African-American
afro-caribbean
no I'm none of these yeah it looks like
that's a no why do you have a biological
mother father sister or brother yes
there you go wow all right
okay do you have Lupus expand to review
your answer oh boy based on your answer
you don't seem to you marked one or more
risk factors for example that I'm 18 to
44. that's a risk factor
yeah see here's the here's where it gets
dice
do we have a definitive answer though
well I am 15 to 44 so I mean you know
let's not take this too lightly that is
suspicious they're not giving me an
answer there oh cool
I can laminate it for you
for you answer you answered where's the
give me the verdictions
I'm trying I can't get out of this
print page man it won't let me
cancel
keep it going based on your answer you
don't seem to be experiencing any of the
symptoms we asked about that's great
oh thank God oh my god well listen
listen before you judge me too hard
please
these are medical professionals at the
peak of their field they put me through
put this website together yeah
absolutely I wasn't like yo please
please I need to see the I need
to see the hematologist no that's he
said why don't we do this and follow up
on it right
okay how old are you love uh 22. oh you
could be over here
Dan how old are you I'm uh how old am I
36 lupus oh Olivia yeah
so we'll see obviously I'm I'm relieved
by this okay I have a question
cautiously really because there is still
something going on you know
with the blood cells the white blood
cells the red blood cells the
inflammation something's happening thump
something's happening maybe I'm turning
into a X-Man
maybe you're mutating maybe I'm uh
yeah mutating I'm looking some sort of
superpower so they're so that's my lupus
update and I've pledged to be uh up
front and you know transparent with
everybody
so that's that's the news
all right
fantastic
um we're at 42 minutes we should do our
Gamers
this is serious
go to gamer Subs
okay because it's all happening right
now
gamersups.gg
okay
thank you for that dude that
background's sick hen thank you go to
gamersubs.gg I want to play this game
looks like a deuce dude
sure yeah
straight here
is that what it's called Dux Deus Ex
Deus isn't it French no it's Latin
how do you spell do in French
well I French is relating related highly
related to Latin okay so how do you know
it's Latin and not French what does that
expression comes from the ancient times
so you say actually two is d-e-u-x too
originally came from uh from Greece
right so you claimed
anyways about no because French is a
derivative of Latin yes right yeah yes
to establish that but that doesn't mean
all French is Latin it's of course not
I'm speaking Yeah so is you know I'm
speaking Latin no you're not you can't
speak what
you can't
they don't allow it moving deadline the
dead language they don't allow it
anymore
moving on guys go to gamersupps.gg
okay
we have formulated this flavor and this
is what it looks like sick in the oh the
key's out help me out here in a little
bit
uh stand by stand by stand by drop in
the green screen in three two I got it
one and oh wow it's a beautiful color
wow very satisfying yes
um kind of like a beautiful teal yeah
yeah
um we have formulated this flavor
in the Laboratories of the H3 podcast
Studios feverishly
painstakingly tweaking the flavors
tweaking the ingredients
spicy Margarita America no the world's
favorite cocktail
flavor the universe it's it's a little
spicy a little bit
it's sweet and tangy
it is the perfect flavor
and I saw some people like wondering
it's not Spice in your throat you just
feel oh no it's lightly on your tongue
it's simply just like it's just a little
bit if you're adverse to spicy stuff you
will be 100 fine yes yeah I promise
I promise it's just a little like um
what is that um
um
I love it man
uh here's here's some you get 10 off by
the way if you go to
gamersupps.gg use the code H3 you get 10
off bada bing bada boom Bob is your
uncle confirmed
uh it won't break you it won't break
your keto because there's no sugar in it
it's got caffeine keeps me energized and
hyped and by the way
I'm out on coffee I just it's just not
that good you know and it it's super
acidic it up my stomach
this on the other hand is four to five
with minerals
water to hydrate no Brown sludge
whatever that is coffee
this is the real deal right here they
also have a caffeine free flavor for
anyone who's avoiding caffeine there you
go that's what I'm drinking if you're
addicted to sodas oh you're avoiding
caffeine cam
desperate right now I like I like I
don't want the caffeine kick from the
camera same here
oh you're doing not caffeine too yeah
yeah yeah because I drink a lot I I use
it as like a cold beverage so okay I'll
drink one caffeine and then the rest did
you feel it if you drink too much
caffeine yeah yeah definitely
so I keep it to one or two caffeine and
then the rest to clean so um
if you're drinking sugary drinks it's
time to stop
because
you know the calories that you're taking
in from that is just not worth it my
friends
switch to gamer Subs which is sugar-free
you know
and uh actually a lot of people are
using gamer Subs as a gateway to a
healthier lifestyle
myself included
I love it I'm so I'm actually so proud
of this flavor we've made and I hope you
guys will consider supporting it
that's gamersupps.gg use the code H3 for
10 off your purchase and thank you so
much to gamer subs for being a wonderful
supporter of this show
appreciate them
thank you
yes
yes yes
[Music]
do what do how do you say it do
ax Deus exactly so what does deus ex
mean from God from God or God from God
from God from the machine
yeah
that's when God Saves the Day we have
done 40 minutes and we literally have
done three things out of like a hundred
correct actually more than 100 frankly
and incorrect we've actually done 48
minutes
only here on the H3 podcast can we do
that you know what I mean we're the best
and that's how we come here four times a
week five of you include the members
stream and do three and a half hours for
you guys
that's how we don't run out of to
talk about
because we don't talk about anything we
put it off for as long as possible
um
Jordan Peterson was on Theo Von's
podcast you know I like theobon I say
that he I think he's a good guy I think
he's super funny he doesn't usually get
like very a lot of his friends are like
and Associates
are um
Joe roganites but he doesn't usually
dabble on and he's very funny I've liked
him from the beginning so a friend of
the show as well
but anyway uh Jordan Peterson was on his
uh broadcast
I'm not quite sure how Theo Von who's
like not really a very serious person
like he's very silly about everything is
going to have this high level
intellectual conversation
with Jordan Peterson but let's find out
the Rat King I mean versus uh
the transphobe king I don't know like
the Xanax King well
well this is the theory now I don't know
if people ever did this so imagine your
village is full of rats oh yeah okay so
now you go oh so this all started when
he told Jordan he's called the Rat King
right
and he had to bust out some knowledge
Catch 10 routes okay you throw them in a
pit okay soon
there is one route
because he gets all the other raps he's
the champ
didn't you throw 10 more routes in there
what do you mean he gets all the other
rats you have ten rats in a fight and
they kill each other he gets them gets
him
he gets them
soon there's one route you do that three
or four times then you take the
remaining rat and you let him go
and soon there are no rats in the
village really
that's the theory wow so he it was like
the toughest of them all yeah and then
he learns to eat rats wow that must be
some sort of ancient wisdom that he's
citing uh oh no he did not quote
this movie get the rats off an
island
my grandmother showed me I always wonder
sometimes when you've heard these like
pseudo-intelligent people where they
come up with this this man pull is
this equilibrium no this is James Bond
it's even worse yeah I mean this is
Skyfall
he's quoting the villain from Skyfall
take a listen and change the lead then
we wired coconut to the leader spade and
the Rats would come for the coconut time
they would fall into the Trap
it's awesome
you just leave it
okay I have not seen this movie but what
the is this scene you're walking
through damn slow it's the introduction
to the villain it just is built up I'm
sorry he's standing there perfectly
still and this guy's walking towards him
like
madnessingly like quarter steps it is a
weird shot no I'm sorry but nobody's
standing still for that long they begin
to get look at this
it's just that casual sorry but I never
seen anybody walk that slow in my life
it's not plausible I mean it's very slow
you're not wrong
you stop eating each other
also he starts he's talking quite low
right yeah this man started talking to
him in this same volume all the way over
here I can't hear you it's
I cannot hear what he's saying
I'm telling you there's issues with this
movie you know you know what a big
problem with this movie is it's like
we're seeing this but it's like who's
there there's there another person in
the room like whose perspective are we
even watching right now no that's
established I know how cameras work Dan
it seems questionable
so how do you get rats off an island how
do you get cigarettes sorry
I'm I am 100 with Ethan thank you this
is such a weird ass shot and he's
talking in the same tone the whole way
through it's like sorry
I can't hear you it's a movie it
stretches believability I don't care
yeah the Acoustics in that rumor prob
insane yeah and from that far all you
hear is
doesn't make sense dude I'm not
suspending my disbelief for this
all right Jordan however heard every
damn word
it doesn't look menacing he looks silly
why is he walking so slow
like are you okay sir you haven't seen
this one you haven't seen I haven't seen
this one oh it's a good one he like he
took like a cyanide pill so he's like
all up oh for real yeah yeah
that's like kind of the origin of the
yeah the villain oh but not in this shot
not in this shot no okay because I was
like oh he took his finite not not he's
not dying in the scene he's not he's not
all there sure sure
he's a slow Walker I'm too there are
only two left
this guy will get killed in New York
City man
can you imagine someone walking that
slow
you're absolutely murdered dude he
wouldn't make it out alive until they're
not only
and then what do you kill him
you take I do love this actor release
them into the trees it's a great scene
it's not oh this is the uh flip a coin
guy yeah he's great I love him
no they only eat rat now why is he
looking down at him what the uh the
perspective makes no sense okay Chad did
he sit down yeah he's Chad saying he's
tied up yeah he's tired of him oh he's
tied up but like look at the perspective
okay so he's sitting he's sitting with
his arms Oh I thought he was just really
short but look look how the camera goes
forward hold on hold the phone the
camera goes forward it's head level
okay now it's looking up okay wow I see
what happens you thought you knew more
than Roger Dickens about how to shoot a
movie if I was Roger Deacon whoever the
that is this scene would have been
a lot cooler
okay and then what do you kill him no
no you take them and release them into
the trees
but now they don't eat coconut anymore
now they only eat rat
so is this not a proverb or something or
is this enough is this like he actually
got it from James Bond movie it has to
be coconuts and Barbados I'm sure it
probably is some like little folk tale
that's been told for a while yeah I mean
it's funny but I like to think that he
got it from a James Bond villain though
yeah
that does seem likely because he's
obsessed with media so I wouldn't be
surprised it's like you know when the
James Bond movie he said that rats eat
each other instead of the Coconuts then
they didn't want the Coconuts anymore
they just wanted rats rats will dance
for money if you pay them don't you
understand
Twitter is a rat hole they trained me to
eat the rats
the Rat Hole
oh here but here's an unrelated one Theo
Vaughn just came out uh
powerfully against his old podcasting
Network
I've been talking to him a little bit
about it
this is a pretty crazy story
actually is that clip in here because I
see yeah yeah yes
oh here it is yeah yeah
so he he was asking me like man how do
you do this because
you know I have a bit of a reputation I
want to talk about uh he's like I've
never done this I was like dude ain't
nobody ever get away with me
over that's the deal
so he talked to you before he did this
yes oh and you encouraged him to do it I
encourage him to do it yeah oh I didn't
realize you were like well I was like
look it look just you know
see that's funny that I wouldn't give
anyone else this I want to give myself
this advice but I would say I said just
clear with the lawyer you know about
what you say and stuff
um
but he did it and I'm I'm happy for him
I'm proud for him because these snakes
these con men these thieves in
this business they need to be humiliated
they need to be uh push a light shined
on and apparently
cast which is a huge podcast you network
now I don't work with any of these
you guys know me I'm I'm
independent
but apparently
as theovan explains in this clip they
were
paying them less and less so how it
works in this business without something
is you you do the ads then the the
company in between uh collects the money
and then pays you like within a few
months after or sometimes it takes even
longer I don't know why
and so he said as they were working he
they got less and less money and this
dude was just keeping all the money and
apparently he stole like four million
dollars
from uh him and his friends in this
network okay that has been tough for
it's I want to talk about something
um
we our podcast was defrauded we were
stolen from
um we were taking advantage of a lot of
ways to say it uh the company that did
it is cast media and I thought they were
like a big reputable company
we talked about them before I just don't
recall why I I sort of remember the name
I see in my history but I don't recall
why I feel like someone else was
complaining about them
oh I guess maybe I shouldn't say it
publicly Whitney maybe I should beep
that out yeah
I said Bobby but maybe it's fine I'm
just guessing
yeah yeah I'm just guessing I don't
remember but he said a bunch of his
friends got stolen from so you you know
you can you can use your imagination
there
the man that did it is Colin Thompson
and I'm gonna put I love that too you
know how I love that but this
picture he says his name hell yeah and
that man is Ryan Kavanaugh oh no sorry
different start just kidding Ryan has
nothing to do with this
that was just a joke
picture in here
um
and
uh it's
I don't know exactly how to say this I'm
gonna do my best
um we're part of a larger group of
podcasts that were uh stolen from
right we were part the in total I would
suggest going watching it
but the weird Shady thing is um
Tai Lopez is with cast media yeah
knowledge my brother knowledge they're
like luckily his podcast didn't ever
make any money
you're in my garage uh we got no
problems nobody think like Logan Paul
was with cast media I think all kinds of
money people were
[Music]
um
but it's weird so this company cast is
going they're filing for bankruptcy
apparently
but at the same time no no no I don't
think so that's what Theo told me he
told me I guess there so lot live one
which is another big ass no podcast one
is another big ass podcasting company
okay who's trying to get their IPO
together
now okay so what it is is there's a
company live one that podcast one is a
subsidiary of and they're trying to spin
off podcast one into its own business
and take that public
so it's currently owned by live one
but soon they want to make podcast one a
standalone company
so anyway podcast one is acquiring cast
[Music]
who owes people all this money
and then apparently according to what I
heard is podcast one is now trying not
to pay
which doesn't make any sense to me
because I would I would assume that they
would assume their liabilities I told
Dio you got to sue podcast one
you know what I mean oh and also they're
hiring the guy
that stole
money from all them and then they said
we're not going to pay you back
we're just we're we're gonna give you
stock options in our future IPO for the
money we already owe you that's right
that's up oh hell no
hell no I know who this guy is isn't the
guy
but uh
seems like a really big uh scheme a
really big organized scheme it's real
dirty dirty business man
so I support youthiovan
so when does someone sticking one more
time here because he says it a few times
this is the guy
it just whoever you are the whole thing
to me felt really uh seedy and the worst
part to me was I said well
what about Colin Thompson that guy's a
crook and they said he's gonna be
um he'll be
they said we felt like he's done a good
job and that he would be part of the
team still that's crazy so how I
remember what I said he says how do I do
this like how has it worked for you and
I'll say I'll be honest like sometimes
it works good sometimes it ends up being
a show
but I just would do the right thing
let's see
I was like you know sometimes it works
like bbtv that worked out great
other times you end up getting sued by a
billionaire four times
[Laughter]
so it's kind of a crap shoot you never
know you never know but you do the right
thing and then you
you let the pieces fall where they may
so I know it wasn't easy for him to come
out and do this it's not his uh
it's not his Forte and uh I wish him
well and uh
I hope Justice is served to what did he
what did theoban say again he's gonna be
um what was his name he happens then
we'll get a share of our money right
like it just
the whole thing to me felt really well
here he's put he spells it I just want
you guys to know that this is the man
we put his picture up on the thing on
the YouTube
and the amount of money that I should
have guessed you had something to do
with this this is so Ryan okay well okay
well hold on I didn't give him
specifications I didn't orchestrate the
damn yeah I understand
um people are saying Hassan's old
podcast was on cast media dude they were
they were involved in a lot I don't
understand how could they so oh then
Theo also told me that they're alleging
that they're gonna go bankrupt and
that's why they can't pay anyone back so
the whole thing is really confusing I
see but then somehow at the same time
podcast one is acquiring them I don't
know man
these people are scumbags if I don't
work with them frankly
I'm out bbtv was the last one I was like
still affiliated with they're out
um
yeah it's just the shit's wrong
who is this guy do we know anything
about him Colin Thompson just some
podcast Guru
uh
well it just sounds like he works it's
one of the uh Addies you know what I
mean no they're more than that they do
like the production and stuff and
everything the cast they're like a key
turn uh Solutions you know what I'm
saying
right so he is the founder of fair and
cast media right it's just alone I don't
know yeah his Twitter bios has founder
and CEO oh so his so he's the
guy yeah he's the guy
and you know I love now that they're
hiring him that's like going That's like
Chase Bank going and hiring Bernie
Madoff to uh handle and their their
investment uh portfolio rip to the goat
dude
you know
let's get out let's go ahead and throw
it to detective um Ted Bundy
to investigate these murders
so my my support to uh Theo and all the
other people who got burned I don't know
Cheers Cheers
also moving on I needed your guys
opinion on this because I didn't quite
understand what was the implication of
this
um so a old picture of Tate and his
brother resurfaced
at supper club in London
so I didn't understand gay is it a gay
club is that what it is I don't think
it's specifically that it's a cake so
then what's the I don't understand the
it looks like a burlesque theme at least
yeah oh yeah there's there's women in
the background so so who cared what's
the own I don't get it
to be honest I was a little I kind of
felt the same way oh okay I think just
with their post together I mean it does
look like this theatrical it looks like
they could be at a gay club what is
Supper Club is that I mean they include
the name like it means it's not a
specific Club yeah I looked into it it's
just a name for uh like a place that's
like a bar and hang out it's help coming
it's because I'm an island boy and
including what that they have an
ancestral uh love well he's holding a
whip now yeah BDSM yeah it's like a bit
ironic I think because they're very much
not very Alpha it's not very alpha male
I think not at all
yo brother you want to go to this BDSM
club and maybe it's like an Eyes Wide
Shut type deal you know
uh these two are way too comfortable
doing sexual things in the same vicinity
well yeah you know they
yeah I mean that is true you know that
they and what they do that's the island
boy implication here's the place on
Google Maps with reviews wonder if this
was the gay Bingo night or the one with
the prowling men
I don't know what that means
but okay so apparently uh it's not as
a lot of people did I mean it blew up on
the suburbs that's what I was saying I
needed some clarity because I just
didn't quite get it
um so who is gay I don't know that's
what I was wondering I don't know who's
gay
and frankly it's not our place to ask
okay
I did not fart audibly what the why
would you even say that somebody said
that in chat what
did you because my ass is so far away
from the mic
oh do you even hear that I mean if you
really ripped one you could probably
hear it a little bit so what does it
matter if it's a BDSM club though
I mean we know he's we've never seen a
video of him beating women up and saying
oh we're into that yeah exactly
Ethan you look more Jewish now that
you're losing weight
what does that mean interesting comment
that's I'm gonna call that a backhanded
compliment
you know but thank you I think
not really sure
uh we have a Ryan Kavanaugh update
[Music]
go on
the Jews
uh Ryan kavkau speaking of Jewish World
conspiracies
Brian Kavanaugh's like yeah he's like a
hardcore Jewish guy he's like pro Israel
he's you've seen the emails he sent to
Natalie Portman yeah haranguing her so
imagine how confused that we all were
when he posted Ryan Kavanaugh yes D Ryan
Kavanaugh thank you the disgraced uh
financier
uh failed businessman thank you
multiple failed businessman
um wife being railed by a big beautiful
Israeli man beautiful man gorgeous he is
really stunning yeah he's like maybe 10
out of 10.
are you kidding me of course Brad the
bull
right uh but anyway he posted what Jesus
can only be described as the most
unexpected and bizarre
uh
uh conspiracy video and let's pull it up
the conspiracy one or the we disavow
this and oh good call
just to make it very very clear to uh
uh the we just we no no just about the
opposite yeah yeah we disavow everything
said by this loser right so Ryan said
quote can't believe how spot-on this
book is time to reclaim the narrative
from media and social media no more
coincidences now as we watch this
remember that Ryan Cavanaugh is a Jewish
socialite social media owner yes thank
you he is too dumb to know that they're
literally talking about him yeah listen
to this he posted this to his
right have an official and prior
to that he was a Hollywood executive
British Hollywood executive which is the
other people that they're talking about
in this video yes both of them the ADL
has also given an award for his
philanthropy he's like the perfect
Maelstrom of
conspiracy anti-semitic conspiracy uh
right I mean well as you'll see they
don't explicitly say Jews yeah but
anyone with the brain knows well we're
talking about here it is this is
goddamn page controlled by
globalist technocrats appears to become
true Global technocrat okay that means
Jew oh globalist let's see a book titled
to the conspirators hierarchy the
committee of 300. Coleman claims that an
international committee led by the
Bilderberg Group and Western
intelligence agencies would steer the
world towards a dystopian future in
which four billion useless eaters would
be eliminated by 25. right Kavanaugh
you're posting this to your Instagram
page angry
4 billion useless eaters are going to be
exterminated Ryan
he says I can't believe that spot on
this book is the
D3 limited Wars organized epidemics and
starvation today the world is witnessing
a limited war in Ukraine
warns that the U.S could be at war with
China by 2020. that's super interesting
considering the US has been at War
continually for like 30 years
so but now all of a sudden oh it's all
adding up shut up
dumbass all right the covid-19 pandemic
has also allowed authoritarian
governments to impose Mass lockdowns
economic turmoil he really postages you
guys official all of which align with
Commons predictions other predictions
from the book include the promotion of
compulsory what would you do if like
someone close to you posted this to
their main
that's concerning that's just uh the
first time did he say there's gonna be
compulsory pornography in school did he
say that compulsory
pornography in school yeah it's called
sex ed bro that's probably what they're
talking about but kids are going to be
forced to look at infected genitals
forced pornography and cheese the
destruction of Industry nuclear energy
the control of Agriculture and food
production by the committee of 300 with
a push for green energy that cannot
sustain current energy demands does any
of that sound familiar in 2023 the
liberal media is obsessed with promoting
drag queens in schools agricultural
production has been taken over by the
global distance
for sure
all right but seriously if like some
like your uncle or maybe uncles are
crazy you have a reputation for that but
like someone you're close with like a
friend posted this
that would be a cause for concern right
yeah yeah or you just be like damn that
dude's dumbass
this seems like something my friends
would post yeah I mean people through my
life that definitely reports this but
this man is like a high level executive
who's main posting this yeah sorry
about a this dumbass here very
dumb God he looks
[Music]
oh really
he does literally yeah I agree I'm not
even saying that to be like
I know what you're doing Dan
no not okay I'm not going to go back and
say it but literally because of the
color of his skin and the way he looks
it looks like he'd be rolling in mud you
know what I mean more comfortable
rolling in mud than anything
all right let's move on uh but boy he
looks bad boy and he's you better be
putting on some moisturizer too boy
because I'm telling you man or I mean
not moisturizer sunscreen
thank you
God damn that is a pasty hideous look
come on okay sorry I just got caught up
in the moment okay
um wow he's posting these prices oh
Jesus dude
his Instagram like if you're a potential
investor
just look at this all right Paige what
do you mean look at his engagement it's
so good you should look at some of the
comments
right let's look at his this one 30 000
likes no way
let's strive for a better future it's so
weird how many people say inspiring
inspiring love this post Ryan inspiring
fantastic post Ryan inspiring thumbs up
yeah investors might
fall for this the comments but yeah the
posts are wild
it's the psycho posting so enlightening
keep it up brilliant thank you for
sharing wow incredible Insight yeah so
apparently four billion people are going
to be uh murdered because they're
useless feeders that is so inspiring wow
we should speed that up I love your
perspective Ryan inspiring
crazy isn't it
what a phony off their land in
order to comply with the crippling World
economy it's incredible to me that this
dude who's like
trying to be a social media executive
working with Bryce Hall and the demilios
can be so inept so incompetent at
actually using social media it's
eye-opening
the whole thing has been eye-opening
when you say enlightening
yeah inspiring inspiring and inspiring
good Ryan this is inspiring I'm so
inspired Ryan energy targets the result
is being tragic I'm being serious though
it has the whole Ryan Kavanaugh Saga has
been enlightening about I think that
there are a lot of Ryan Kavanaugh's in
this world right you know who just fail
their way through life and that's it
he's the net he's like he fails his way
up this man has done nothing but fail
yeah and fail colossibly yeah and yet
he's still somehow be dishonest and just
in my opinion dishonest and it judges
opinion
in my opinion uh dishonest you know
little weasel of a man
um it's just he's just a fraud in every
way and people still work with him yep
why
inspiring Money Talks yeah right he's
inspiring
yeah his crazy thing about Ryan though
he comes from a family of crooks
in my opinion allegedly maybe maybe
probably I don't know something about
his dad I don't remember what it said
something about forging paintings or
something I don't know Picasso
I don't remember but it's all alleged
but you can look it up yourself uh
the New York Times says media Executives
father ordered to pay 250k and Sue over
fake Picasso there it is thank you New
York Times according to New York Times
reporting was there ever a correction on
that article uh not that I'm seeing no
okay no correction okay
does it say okay good thank you
just to give the whole you know
so there that is Ryan Kavanaugh we love
you buddy
Thriller is gonna bring you right back
to the status you lost
what uh is the deal with that
movie dude I feel like that movie's been
in the cam for like three years now
you know how long Schindler's List took
to me
stop uh can't rush you can't rush is
there a police state like he just says
2024. the way February 2024 February
that's exciting February I feel like
we've been talking about this for years
we have this is going to be like even
worse low budget less watched than
Addison raised she's all that that was
pretty that was like I think the the
production on that was top tier yeah it
was pretty good it was Netflix right
yeah also this whole concept correct me
if I'm wrong I'm not I'm not in tune
with the youngins these days but like
this whole it's the skill House movie
right it's like a satire parody of like
the influencer like mansion house thing
are do those even like exist in the same
way no no we're a little late yeah that
feels like such a dated concept already
that is like they didn't strike well the
iron was hot like if this movie had come
out four years ago it might have done
well just based off of the names and
everything but it just this is such a
disaster
I think they know it too that's probably
why they keep pushing it back let's see
if 50 Cent could carry it home yeah
maybe 50 Cent I mean he's he's highly
accredited actor thespian some people
call him 50 Cent really crazy
credentials
he was he was a he was nominated for
something fitty get rich and died trying
yeah
anyway here's Ryan and the happy family
yeah don't be mistaken by the
familiarity that's his ex and she's
this Beast
do we know that that guy actually is
Israeli
ride the bull you said that earlier I
don't know if we actually know I don't
I'm I'm so sure he is you know what I
mean I'm so sure he is
that's not deaf can you imagine he sues
me for defamation he said I was Israeli
[Laughter]
scumbag now that man is Israeli come on
there's no other possibilities I'll tell
you what though she ain't smiled this
big in a while boy
put a smile on her face
uh but you know what I mean not not to
King sham or I mean we love all
relationships they're all beautiful and
wholesome
oh Ryan Cavanaugh calls out Natalie
Portman email oh brother don't even get
me started
all right moving on yeah
God there's so much to get to what time
which we should probably get into some
of the main stuff I suppose
um although well there is some funny Jay
Shetty stuff oh interesting
um Martin actually called out Jay Shetty
our water smolier
oh this is a tragic day or having Jay
shedding shoes
some quack ass water Guru on
and I knew when I saw this I was like
Shetty are you really that guy right now
get a load of this
this guy just won podcast of the year
thank you Martin for bringing truth to
the people
not a single ounce of that is in this
form if I drink this water it's gonna
feel good it's gonna feel like I'm
hydrating myself for a few minutes
but I'm gonna pee this out in the next
45 minutes because this pure water has
no Reservoir in my body yeah correct
the vast majority of it I mean this is
pure nonsense this guy and then what
Shady you don't you don't look into this
you don't ask him any questions you know
what I mean I think Shetty even posted
this on his main social this guy's
talking about crazy water within my
body is actually water my body's
actually made of crystals for this to
turn into a crystal it takes a complex
relationship to uh the ray of salts
mineral amino acid reflexes and protein
structures let's get some facts for this
video hello everybody here's Matthew
personal water so many so first of all
it's not true that water needs to be
crystallized to be absorbed by your body
I think it gets I think those are called
uh
uh stones
bladder stones to kidney stones oh I see
weird yeah I don't think you want water
crystallizing in your body don't think
so but minerals and electrolytes what
needs to be in water to actually absorb
water so hydration is the key of H2O
plus electrolytes like calcium magnesium
sodium potassium this is what your body
needs to absorb water but Water by
himself does not need to be crystallized
additionally your body is very
sophisticated it knows how much water
it's needed so that's the reason we are
slightly thirsty Therefore your body
signalized us you need to drink water
and because water is a liquid it gets
absorbed very very fast up to five
minutes after drinking has already been
absorbed by your body and it really
depends on your hydration of how fast
you have to go to the restroom after
drinking water go ahead if I take up to
20 minutes when you're fully hydrated or
are you watching this sheddy hours when
you're dehydrated so no it has nothing
to do with the form of water culture how
fast you have to go to the restroom so
this whole idea of water needs to
recrystallized to be absorbed by your
body is sorry nonsense cheers my friends
and remember water it's not just water
sometimes it's crystals also
I mean if you use your brain a little
bit you can just this is obviously such
nonsense he goes yeah if you're drinking
water you think it's hydrating you but
it doesn't at all it just plastes right
through you
what
we all know that's not true right
have you ever been thirsty yeah that's
it's actually your body lying to you it
wants crystals thirst is like the most
basic survival Instinct to animals that
have all lived on this planet you get
thirsty you drink water
now that's actually
I'm telling you man it's not like that
and Jason is like oh yeah crystals bro
I feel like I'm hydrating myself for a
few minutes but I'm not but I'm gonna
pee this out in the next 45 minutes
because this pure water has no Reservoir
so according to you dummy
when you pee out water it should be
perfectly clear because if there's any
yellow in it
then it means your body's processed it
dumbass loser who is this idiot
yeah what uh I need Crystal I spoke some
crystal meth actually before coming on
here I love Christmas
a lot of crystals methamphetamines
they're all good
yeah Shetty that's right I'm watching
I'm paying attention
and I haven't forgotten
I heard Shetty had covet and was trying
to infect the president
that's just based on uh the thing I
invented in my mind right now based on
the guy inside my head
yeah Shetty got close to the president
weapons aren't the only thing that can
kill a president especially at that age
they do it right just look at him once
rozzo is about to retire dude the gays
of Miracles are right damn here
I'm not feeling his hair right here so
much he belongs in the Oval Office
wow shetty's hair looks better now than
it did then oh yeah for sure he got he
did something nice so it did yeah
it's just off all right shady I see you
I'm watching
crystals
all right let's talk about a passenger
of eight eight passengers this story was
something we talked about last week a
big and developing story about this
freak Ruby Frank
Frankie who uh was running a surprise
surprise a family Vlog channel right
here on YouTube
and um surprise surprise she was
committing severe child abuse on her
kids uh actually and this is triggering
so I guess put on your ear muffs for the
next five uh 10 seconds she was duct
taping her kids hands and feet
and starving them to the point where
this all came out because her youngest
daughter who's like 12
son or one of the kids who's really
young broke out of the basement
ran to the neighbor's house with duct
tape on his wrists and ankles and begged
for water and food Jesus and he had open
cuts on his body too yeah he had to be
taken to the hospital to address his
wounds that's up and the other
kids that they retrieved from the house
had to be taken and you know what was
happening to me well she was she was um
filming a mommy
a mommy podcast upstairs with her
partner right how to be a good mommy
starts with good duct tape
good being a good mommy starts with
Gorilla Tape the right type of tape
so um the story's been developing
uh one of the neighbors said they've
been trying to interfere for at least a
year so more is coming out that suggests
that
the authorities the Utah Division of
Child Family Services have known about
this
they had long been worried about the
kids
a neighbor stated that Ruby kicked her
husband Kevin out of the home last year
that was another question we had about
like the husband's involvement yeah
there's some stuff about him in this
it's
a little unclear what he's doing right
now and how much he partook in but he
was present for like all of their
vlogging and stuff so people aren't
letting him off the hook yet
he does like I don't want to give him
too much benefit of the doubt but the
dynamic of this relationship definitely
would suggest that it's possible that he
was also a uh it's definitely a Coke
perpetu a CO he could be both
perpetrator and a victim
because for sure that dude's a victim of
her she's just everyone's a victim of
that freak
um they said that hurt their her
youngest daughter would roam around the
neighborhood
and it seemed that she wasn't in school
that is like so sad to me
especially when you see how in the
middle of nowhere they lived
um just kidding they don't apparently
live in the middle of nowhere
um continuing
we know that chat so Chad's the husband
now who's Chad no Chad is their oldest
son Kevin okay Chad's that poor guy who
lost his bedroom privileges yes we know
that Chad lived with Kevin and Ruby
and the other four kids we don't know if
Kevin made efforts to gain custody of
the other kids
so
Kevin Chad live with Kevin
okay the oldest was living with his dad
and Ruby had the other four who she was
actively torturing
but now what I understand is the father
gained custody of all the kids right so
page six reported
um that so his lawyer released a
statement that said his urgent focus is
to Simply keep his children together
under his fatherly care and Page Six
took that as the kids are staying with
him but it doesn't definitively say so I
didn't necessarily wanna
I mean it's suggested if that was his
statement well do we have a statement
that's literally the entire statement
what is it in here oh yeah here it is so
he released in in the scope of all these
terrible things coming out
the dad Kevin Frankie released one tiny
short statement through his lawyer he
said
urgent focus is simply to keep his kids
together under his fatherly care
that's it
like does that mean he's trying to get
access to all of his kids so that he can
keep them safe or is he saying that he
has them
more or so about who has custody yeah
I'm just kind of trying to understand
why so little was said and usually when
you put out statements that are so
succinct and through a lawyer it's just
to basically
um reduce your liability
so this man is definitely
trying to cover his ass right now in
that statement there's no other way to
really interpret that
urgent focus is simply to keep his kids
together under his fatherly care yeah I
mean it's pretty cryptic
what does fatherly care bro I don't like
that it sounds we already tried that
when the Mormon Church the fatherly care
thing these kids need a different
approach
the father you know I mean the father
let those kids get duct taped in a
basement where were you
right
like even if he was a victim I mean he
should have like gone taken on that
don't you think
yeah yeah it's hard because if he does
too much it's gonna get like completely
shut out probably from the courts right
it's true it's not that simple I guess
not that like the neighbors tried
I would love to know kind of I I hope it
comes out what his involvement really
was right what he's been doing to try to
help his kid
but Kevin was part of connections which
is this podcast Ruby started with her
freak business partner who was keeping
the kids in her basement this woman Jody
dude the Dateline is gonna be so sick on
this
it's probably already they're probably
working on it dude those those fiends
don't miss yeah 2020 Dateline they're
they're out there right now
NBC reported that Ruby Frankie as well
as Jody her business partner have been
formally charged with six counts of
felony child abuse each count carries a
prison sentence of up to 15 years and a
fine of ten thousand let's go
what are the chances that they get
90 years though that's not happening
right zero probably yeah but why not
they should never they should never be
released they're obviously a danger to
society and to their children I mean if
I was one of her kids I would not want
to know that my mom was back out free
okay so there was another part of the
story so her her eldest daughter had put
together a Google Document
to organize
all of the misdoings of her mom to have
it keep it all in one place so that if
she needs it in court or otherwise she's
got it and it was just a huge document
so
we went and grabbed some stuff out of it
and here's four things that her own
daughter highlighted
here's Ruby saying her kids are starving
but they can eat until they do they
cannot eat
until they do chores and my kids are
literally starving I hesitate to say
this because it's gonna sound like I'm
like a mean Barbarian but I told the
kids I said I'm not even gonna let you
eat breakfast until you get your chores
done if I let you
this is a common uh Motif I found in her
she withholds food from children it's
gross
that's like your basic
obligation
is to feed your damn kids
they didn't ask to be born
you know what I mean they did not ask to
come out of you
you made that choice for them the least
you could do is feed them
so crazy
the weather word thing is her sister
made some kind of statement that was
like
suggestive that they had a normal
childhood which I don't know how you
become this up from like a normal
upbringing I don't know
I don't I don't know I don't know if
it's possible and my kids are literally
starving I hesitate to say this because
it's gonna sound like I'm like a mean
Barbarian but I told the kids I said I'm
not even gonna let you eat breakfast
yeah yeah I hope you enjoy the food in
prison
enjoy the the gruel
oh God damn dude that thumbnail looks
insane right now hold on I gotta order
my lunch
everybody
uh you sent me a Discord and she pulled
up like a image of the food
oh oh you're freaking out about the food
yeah bro
yeah we're in we're in it for the long
haul people so we gotta eat that's right
you guys take take comfort in knowing
that I'm ordering right now because
um that means we're here
uh yeah I had lunch are you you don't
think okay you don't need anything no
short up today
you don't need anything there Ian yeah I
had lunch okay cool so you never need
anything
what am I feeling today I don't want to
go too crazy you know
there's this Mexican food cart we get
from
[Music]
you know let's get out of here let's go
tostada burrito yo that sounds kind of
fascinating
tostada burrito what makes it ow I don't
know I mean I might hit the all meat
burrito those are gnarly bro well I
don't like I know like I've seen that
some places do that yeah I think it's
authentic I seen like it's like kind of
Hardcore but it's literally just meat I
love that it's it's a it's pretty
intense
tell me about it looks good okay go for
it
now I like a little meat but the all
meat is just doing too much in my
opinion I'm the opposite I don't like
the other you don't like I don't
necessarily need just meat but
you know the I got you
yeah I don't with that I got you
you know what I think I'm gonna try this
uh tostada burrito know your way around
some meat soft tostada burrito
give it a shot
[Music]
thank you give it a whirl thank you so
much
[Music]
thank you thank you with peace and love
uh moving on thank you everybody
uh love have you ever had a horchata no
oh wait is that the milk it's rice milk
and cinnamon oh I have had that yeah
that's delicious you like it yeah that's
absolutely I'm gonna say you should get
one but you can if you want yeah
I like them a lot it's like a liquid um
yeah right yeah yeah yeah sure sure
so moving on uh Ruby is taking Christmas
away from the kids she's literally the
Grinch
laughs
wow yeah and by the way this woman is
apparently like heart she's a Mormon
because well you don't get to celebrate
you know it's his birthday if you're a
bad kid you get to do silly woman I'm
like it's not kind of like a like a big
day in your religion yeah kind of like
the biggest it's a privilege sorry Jesus
you'll have to wait till next year
I don't know if people are gonna here
she is uh no no Christmas presents for
their selfish young children
shut up
shut up knowing people these days I
don't know dude she's whatever she
starts with I don't think I should share
this
you know it's going to be good yeah
people these days are way too sensitive
but yes I starve and humiliate and chain
and uh torture and torment my kids okay
fine
people are gonna you know how they're
gonna respond
um so Kevin and I
children the two youngest are showing
long patterns of selfishness they have
been showing bro you're talking about
kids Dom me how old are they long
patterns of selfishness what the
you're talking about like what a
four-year-old
you selfish little
you know also you know what could cause
selfishness like hoarding being forced
to hoard things because your mom is
chronically taking it away and you don't
trust your parents
are you youngest are showing long
patterns of selfishness they have been
showing um
through their choices their
unwillingness to repent their
unwillingness to get sorrow over some
pretty egregious Choice how old are her
youngest wait let's hear the egregious
choices that these four-year-olds repent
hold on
I need to hear her out first that's what
they've made
um
so Kevin and I have decided that we are
going to get I think it's a truth to
them this year for Christmas we are
going to give them the gift of gifts of
Truth she even made a little damn oh
she's got a girlfriend you did a graphic
for this Gifts of Truth validation
vulnerability curiosity
Clarity Christmas repentance boundaries
love empathy compassion forgiveness
who's forgiving who
this chart is not very clear because are
those three like at the bottom honest
honesty responsibility humility are the
three columns above in those categories
are we I think it's safe to say that she
did not draw this inspiration from any
established yeah this is a Doctrine
validation
vulnerability curiosity and Clarity is
part of honesty
okay
forgiveness repentance boundaries these
are all the things
that I don't care about boundaries
boundaries
now are 10 and 12. so I wonder how long
ago this was
now who cares so many of the chats have
four and six no shot she was saying her
four-year-old is showing signs of
selfishness
whoa you're a demon actually wow I hate
her she is so vile
she's so vile
why would you do that the beautiful
sweet
kids
somebody donated and said she seems to
be extra cruel to the youngest oh you're
supposed to be extra cruel to the middle
child yeah get the memo and you get the
memo oh keto Jackson oh my God that
makes my heartbreak for this poor kids
man
everyone deserves a mom they trust and
love not this freak
this is like a big part of why uh School
food is free in Sweden and the argument
behind it is for kids who's like poor or
have have like weird families at home
for them to at least have one meal a day
and I think it's so weird that
you guys don't yeah that's why they do
it here that's why we do it here too
it's just we don't give a right
exactly some places do it yeah it's so
bizarre and then some places are like
man those starving kids it's their own
damage like it doesn't even have to be
that good like just some rice like
some actually I think it's even worse in
America I think there's like a large
percent of kids who get their hot most
calories from the free school lunch like
it's like an alarmingly high percentage
of kids yeah
food insecurity rates are really crazy
California has free lunches right Dan
pretty sure we do that we rock back here
for school yeah uh yeah yeah when I was
a kid we didn't
well it wasn't universally free just for
low income yeah they had uh these like
tickets they hand out
how does a kid how does a kid with like
negligent parents prove that he's low
income
yeah no you can't you know what I mean
yeah
they'll like prove it
you need to bring me your parents pay
stubs prove it
stupid crazy prove it so so we sat down
with them
we we told these two
um what our expectations were again
and we let them know how deeply
sorrowful we've been because of the
choices that they've been making they
play what
sorrowful oh sorrowful
guys I have a four-year-old son and he
is very mature and he's fantastic and he
can honor he understands everything but
the idea of sitting down and giving this
this boy a like uh
ultimatum
to not be selfish I mean this this is
insane
uh last year California began providing
free school lunches to all kindergarten
through 12th graders regardless of
family and income that's cool and that's
why I love this beautiful state
I remember I still remember when I was a
kid because I think a couple years
my family was low income enough that I
had the tickets but other years I didn't
and but I remember the meal was 35 cents
it made me feel really old
because I don't think anything in the
world cost 35 cents it was well we're
back this is the same age mine wasn't
that it was like five bucks or maybe
three bucks or something in elementary
I'm talking like l o like little little
kid oh God I just had another so when I
remember it was my mom would give me a
quarter and a dime to buy lunch that day
I think you're right actually I remember
the quarter in the dime what let me tell
you a story
and this is gonna freak you out love
when I was in kindergarten
there was days when we would go to the
cafeteria or it's like first grade or
something I don't know it was all
elementary school
and I didn't have money
and I would go you'd have to go to the
office and get a loan
alone there was someone in the in the
principal office who would loan you the
35 cents and they would write down your
name wow and make sure that they got
paid back yeah make those kids
pay come on although she was probably
doing something really sweet from just
her own personal wanting to take care of
the kids sure but that's just how
desperate it was there was times when I
didn't have the money and I just didn't
eat
35 cents they just wouldn't serve me
that's so wrong also it's kind
of humiliating that and like you don't
want to ask for help it's just really
humiliating yeah definitely
man
it's up I haven't thought about
that in a while yeah that's sad
really sad
and how it's affected their teachers at
school it's effective their peers it's
affected
um in our home the siblings
um
yo question them
who are these people oh is that her
partner Jody
no who's Walter White here
if you're looking at
siblings
um
we just laid it out very clear and we
told them that
this year they are not going to be
visited by Santa
so they will and we perhaps them we we
let them know that the Santa's dead
Christmas morning
I ca and I killed him
because you don't pick up your clothes
Santa's dead every time you
don't pick up your clothes Santa gets
another bullet hole
for older siblings but did you do Santa
when you were a kid even though your
Jewish house you didn't do Santa at all
not at all
we we did my dad was staunchly
anti-christmas that doesn't surprise me
it was against the hole he was like were
Hanukkah we're Jewish we don't do the
Christmas yeah we did both
yeah we
double dipped in our house we did both
too like Ramadan and Christmas oh there
you go that's fun you got to do
Christmas I mean it's a national holiday
for Christ's sake you know the
Christians
it's about the presence Jesus every
American should have to celebrate
Christmas listen no Jesus is a very very
very secondary aspect of Christmas yeah
that's Santa's Day
take the back seat true
it's not open and that they will have
the gift of love from their dad and I
wow really feel the love them I really
have a visceral experience that shut up
no I was really hoping that like keeping
them home from school and wiping the
floorboards would like really bring pain
like
are you listening to yourself this is
like the on Oliver Twist uh style
boarding home yeah yeah like you're
making them clean the walls and it's an
orphanage
until they suffer so to teach them
suffering I'm like who are you
keeping them home from school and wiping
the floorboards would like really bring
pain should she suffer like oh my God
you really want to change this behavior
that I've been exhibiting and it didn't
it didn't that's because they're for
that's not how you change the behavior
of a four-year-old you dumb
evil
God it wasn't painful for them they're
like oh yeah we get to stay home from
school and clean floorboards this is
kind of fun it's like ah
uh you know and they haven't
they haven't affected them it's because
they're so numb they made the best of
that horrible situation so clearly
I had to punish them further
you know they weren't crying their knees
weren't bleeding it just wasn't enough
them your child is
the greater experience the big the
bigger the outcome they need to wake
them up you're not going to push a
boulder with just your hands you need
some real leverage who the
nominated this woman to even give people
advice as a mother like why are you
she has a family Vlog Channel
like what are your credentials exactly
and uh yeah that's Child Development she
has a family Vlog Channel she's speaking
like she's some damn Guru
and a big house
the biggest leverage that a little child
has is probably Santa Claus and so
I I expressed them that I love your soul
more than anything in this world and I
literally would just be clear I love
your soul you I'll torture
punish
right because she practices
non-unconditional love no she said that
right no condition I love your soul
unconditionally right so that when you
die we'll remember you fondly but until
then but you you suck I hate you
oh you're nasty you are nasty I
hate her to to invite you
into repentance and I know parents say
that I'll do I
what I think most parents are saying is
I would give anything to you if I I
would pay any price monetarily right you
mean a selfless Act of love
that's not what she means is it
I don't know how many parents are
actually willing to put any boundary in
place that would bring a turnaround that
would really bring repentance yes so no
no parent has ever adequately uh
parented their kids before until her
that is our gift our gift is a reflex
roof
child of
how selfish you have shown up and it's
not like once or twice it's not one week
if this is like months and months and
months and months and months you have
shown up this selfish and so I'm going
to reflect truth to you equally which is
about it sounds like torture it's like
you will admit you will submit to the
truth
um
about the equivalent of Santa no should
she suffer yes
yes
all right clap if you think she should
suffer so there's that
wow that was something
really nasty stuff that would really
bring repentance I would love to know
the examples of selfishness that I I
would I I would love to know what in her
opinion yeah she didn't give any
specifics probably because she knows it
sounds absurd yeah wait did we change
food spots yes so um oh I didn't want to
interrupt but ah don't show the screen
we showed the wrong he didn't you're
good thank you um
yeah we realized it was the wrong
restaurant it was a similarly named one
also so you guys don't want from that
one we want this one this is the one
that we've ordered this is the one this
is the good one when you see the
pictures you'll be like oh yeah no yeah
dude that club sandwich looks
crazy because some of you guys might
know this but at Mexican restaurants
they sometimes dish out the craziest
sandwiches hamburgers really
I remember uh because I haven't me in a
long time but yes the uh hamburgers at
the Mexican places they slap hard for no
reason for no reason Enterprise is there
any elements of like Mexican Cuisine in
there or is that a normal version no
it's just kind of an American Burger but
they just know they just do it Grill it
up oh yeah
God damn they got some good ass looking
sandwiches here I didn't know that yeah
they have a burger and you know it slaps
bro yeah
yeah give it a shot I already got my
eyes on something else okay what are you
getting I don't know is it identifying
to say the name no the day every Mexican
restaurant is the same menu California
Burrito I mean yeah yeah like every
place that's a that's a that's an iconic
uh Cali Burrito you got to call it
caliburi calibri California
Burrito frankly but I respect it I
I don't like the french fries in there
it gets that's the uh that's the good
part so then that's why I don't like it
I'm curious if I want chorizo in there
or uh asada
I'm an asada boy the chorizo gets a
little munch
yeah but do you like like ground up
sausage I mean that's yeah I tried it
the other the other week and it was
really yummy so maybe maybe you're a
chorizo boy all right try something new
yeah I'll go for the uh then it
it
[Applause]
bro
yeah this looks insane right now
dude
this looks insane right now
I literally can't there's so many things
I want here
it does look quite good
um while you're figuring that out let me
read it go go ahead Zach we got folks in
the street oh come on Zach really I'm
just getting lunch man it's not that
serious
[Music]
so much dude I'm just getting lunch man
can you give me a break please
bro okay what so I'm not supposed to eat
the lunch fine Oliver you don't look to
me like you skipped many lunches buddy
damn man
so judgmental bro
[Music]
I dude it's easy line just everything
[Laughter]
I've lost a lot of weight Oliver how
dare you judge me first
I've been good all right I think I know
what I'm gonna get I'm I'm afraid I'm
gonna regret it though
no regrets dude no regrets dude the
Malita look crazy right now
those are so heavy though
dude I was eyeing that they're good
they're good
I never seen anything like that here's
what I want Dan I'm writing it you write
it
is it insensitive that we're talking
about starving kids and then ordering
fat Mexican meals nah
I don't see any issues with that
not until you say it like that
I'm starving please I need food and
water
yo those molitas sound good God that
looks good let's just get it all they're
eating now you kids want anything yeah
they're eating good now somebody's
feeding them Dan what do you think about
my choice do you think that's crazy
order or no no I I it's you're right
they got some good sandwiches there too
but then the meat's probably not that
impressive
I I can't I can't comment on that know
your way around some meat you're the
expert all right I'm gonna get that see
what happens let's get it it's fun let's
get it
All Right Moving On
Ruby says she and Jody don't care if
their kids hate them
and again these are the clips
highlighted from her eldest daughter and
a document I have that she's been saving
a very lengthy document right in case
she needs one day
to share this with authorities or
somebody somewhere smart so
here it is this is her and her business
partner she's the lady who's the kids
were tied up in her basement well they
shot the connections mommy gotta have
your business partners back
respect that's just good business
respect I just peed in my basement
suppose before uh oh you gotta have each
other's back pose before baby as you all
know
don't you know when you're great what's
your name Jody yeah just before Joe's or
no Joe's before uh baby doesn't work or
just before babies it doesn't work
all right from a passengers address the
fact that people keep saying that her
kids are not going to talk to her
anymore if she keeps treating them the
way that she has her daughters already
come out and said
if you go forward this is there's a
little commentary over the beginning
it's almost over but a missing video
Ruby just doesn't seem to care buddy and
I have each shared an example from our
own lives of what real love looks like
which isn't what the world thinks is
love they push back and say whoa that's
mean it's not me that it's not the whole
world that's wrong
no it's not
it's me the whole world that's wrong not
me me that usually is correct going to
sometimes it's correct
usually not when you're beating your
kids though
sometimes it's Brave to stand up and be
different yeah unless you but you're
she's just beating her kids right unless
you're starving it yeah right yeah you
know that might be a little too
different starving them like what what's
an example we can think of Martin Luther
the Great reformist
uh yeah like the original Martin Luther
like the one yeah right yeah paper on
the door or Joseph Smith
Joseph Smith the great reformer yeah and
the second problem there's a thread
directly from Joseph Smith to her right
now actually a pretty direct threat yeah
so she's Joseph Smith for a modern day
people say don't beat your kids but I
say
what if what would Joseph Smith do
that's wild like you end up in jail
25 years ago maybe even as recent you
could do anything to your kids pretty
much and nobody would ever say or
ask any questions but this is next level
she's just telling the world about it
I've been over to friend's house when I
was a kid so many times and their dad
just comes out I'm like belts them yeah
I'm not doing that yeah when I was
a kid
I feel like hitting your kids was still
Fair like it was definitely on its way
out but um yeah I definitely had some
friends whose parents smacked him around
it's was scary yeah because I mean my
dad spanked me but he wasn't trying to
hurt me he wasn't angry you know what I
mean yeah
yeah whereas
believe in that even that is seen as you
know really harmful nowadays I would
never do that to my kids right but I
think my dad he's just a product of the
old time he did he doesn't know better
he's doing the best he can you know yeah
all of our parents my dad's probably got
them when they were kids yeah
but it scared the out of me when I
they would do it right in front of me
like they'd come down with a belt and
just start beating the out when it
happened twice in two different houses
damn
like whoa I guess my dad is kind of nice
compared to this right
he loved your children are going to kick
you out of their life
so when people say well if you do that
then your child is not going to trust
you if you do that then your child's Not
Gonna Love You Well exactly I'm just
exactly that my child is refusing
directly conditionally I don't want
anyone in my life who's not going to be
loving so if my child will only love me
if I give them what they want then
that's that's not really love why are
you having so many kids when you clearly
hate children I wonder if Casey Anthony
is up to this channel
probably what the
unconditional love for kids is the
biggest myth facing parents today
in truth
it's true though my son only loves me
when I get him dinosaurs right when he
loves me most
and that's why he has a million
dinosaurs
by their affection Right
this this takes a very strong Soul
because most of us are not even I can't
sorry I could pausing so much they're so
self-congratulatory about being demons
right no they have strong Souls that's
it high level she's like at least a
level 12 thetan yeah
to consider not having our children in
our lives
and I hope that you'll reconsider oh my
God
reconsider having your children in your
lives Jesus think about it everything
wrong with eight passengers in under
eight minutes I don't is this one good
have you seen that 9-1-1 dispatch audio
God damn
Frank Ruby Frankie's sister speaks out
is any of this stuff worth watching
Olivia what do you think are you
familiar with any of this rubyfrank 911
call dispatch audio
yeah the there are a bunch of because
all of the channels were wiped there are
just a bunch of like clips that have
been downloaded and pasted the doc is a
super good uh
like hub for all of the info if you want
like
the good Clips okay well here we have
one more in our document
Ruby left her three and five-year-old
unattended while she was napping and got
angry when they tried to make food dude
I'd be that's that's like real uh
a three-year-old attempting to feed
itself I mean that that's pretty
incredible for that three-year-old
that's that's a lot to ask
like again I keep thinking
you know
my four-year-old son when he was three
the thought of him getting food for
himself was pretty wild so
yeah and Desperation I think
gosh he's such a demon
this is the stuff she's willing to talk
publicly about in a townhouse and there
were a lot of stairs that went up to my
bedroom and the the family room was down
a long flight of stairs and I put my My
Two children my almost six-year-old
she's probably five and then uh Chad my
three almost four-year-olds in the on a
couch and I put on a movie and I said I
am going to go lay down
do not move from your couch you got your
blanket you've gone to the bathroom
um the the doors were locked and bolted
and I said well I'm gonna lay down I
mean I'll put your sister down for a nap
at the baby and I'm gonna go lay down
and when I come down uh I will get some
lunch for everybody or a snack or
whatever it was so they were fed they
were full they were emptied and and so I
thought okay everything's good and I
made it very clear I said do not under
any circumstance go into the kitchen do
not three-year-old I don't know how many
of you all have spent a time with a
three-year-old recently but
can't really make these complicated kind
of requests to a three-year-old do not
go into the kitchen you just stay right
there and watch the movie for an hour
and I went upstairs
and an hour later I came downstairs kind
of psycho to go up to your room and
sleep in the bed yeah I'm not a parent
but you can't leave a three-year-old
alone right oh hell no no that's
crazy right but like if you're gonna
take a nap
do it first of all if you I think most
responsible parents they don't just take
a nap you might just fall asleep because
you're so tired right the idea
of going up into your bedroom
you know is crazy because kids need help
sometimes man A lot of times
yeah like what if like he chokes I don't
know is that a that's a dub for her I
think right yeah it's like that that
wouldn't necessarily teach them
repentance wake her up three-year-old
could need help at any second right at
any moment yeah it's up yeah yeah
and the movie was so going and they were
sitting on the couch and they were
cuddled in their blankets I thought oh
good they did what they were told oh I'm
so glad I'm so relieved okay so I went
into the kitchen to start preparing some
food and as I walked on the floor my
feet went
they stuck they stuck I'm like my foot
is stuck to the floor and as I lifted my
foot up off the forward
like you could you could hear the
stickiness I could hear it with my ears
I thought oh my gosh what is on this
floor and I took another step and my
foot stuck and went like it was like
just sticking on the floor and I thought
what is this so I did what any mother
would do you know what I'm gonna say
yeah moms hi
I knelt down on the floor and I smelt it
and I couldn't I couldn't quite tell and
I stuck my tongue out and I licked the
floor you licked the floor you
weirdo I hope it's
I would not I would smell it if I was
curious what it was I would not lick it
I would not look the floor my tongue
and I licked the floor in my
mind I'll just get on the floor and
everywhere I walked the fact that this
is like such a Calamity in her mind like
a little pineapple juice on the floor
it's pretty wild
put stuck to the floor and I thought
what
how how I'm trying to put it like what
happened so I called my two kids and I
said I said come here and they came over
and I said do you guys know why this
floor is sticky no no
no we don't know
and I said I
this floor was absolutely clean before I
went upstairs I went upstairs for
an hour and I came down and now it is
covered covered there is something
that's going on in one of you or both of
you know something and you're not
telling me
and I'm gonna stand here until you do
and my son said
um
I know I know why it's sticky I said o
and why is that
well
um I thought I cleaned it up but I guess
I didn't
him saying this in his you know three or
four year old vocabulary he showed me
that in the fridge there was a big
Tupperware of pineapple pineapple with
some juice in it and he said I went into
the kitchen
and I got the Tupperware pineapple and I
opened it to get some pineapple and it
spilled and went everywhere and I
hurried and picked up all the pieces of
pineapple and then he he showed me he
said I got a paper towel and I cleaned
up all of the mess and put the lid on
and put it in the fridge so it it
honestly that's pretty sweet yeah of him
to actually do that all that yeah like a
five-year-old do you really expect a
five-year-old's not gonna clean
perfectly but do you understand it was
sticky
yeah it was a very at that moment my
world crumbled upon me what is this
sticky
that's actually really mature and
impressive that that he did that
sounds like a great kid
there was anything wrong well you as
anybody anybody older than four years
old knows that if you have pineapple
juice and you take a paper towel and you
soak up the pineapple juice why are you
not actually cleaning the pineapple
juice you're just making oh my God she's
judging his clean job what the
dude that's crazy every person over four
knows about pineapple and how to clean
the juice obviously
that's a bizarretation so her take is
that you because you're lazy and not a
good person you tried to trick me and do
a bad job on purpose
her mind is a dark place
making it look like there's no pineapple
juice and so I I looked at him
and here's where the compassion comes in
and I hope that you can hear it
I said
I that that's a good thing that you told
me that what you have done
and
you didn't clean it up
you didn't actually clean it up and that
was dishonest so I'm I'm telling him the
truth you said you would not go into the
kitchen and you did I told you under no
circumstance or you two get off the
couch and you did and I told you I would
be feeding you as soon as I come down
and you felt entitled to go take
you felt entitled to take what was in
the fridge and eat it and then you made
a mess and then you tried hiding it by
lying these kids are gonna be so
up man like she's she's she's raising
like
kids that will be you know so
traumatized and incapable of being
honest and all these crazy defense
mechanisms and problems yeah what a
night oh God I hope she suffers in jail
I was raised just like this speaking
from experience this comes from Summoner
I can promise you that those kids are
mentally much older and that the mother
knows exactly what she's doing I'm 31
and still in therapy yeah I mean
that's lifelong trauma what that what's
going on there
sad
well it's pretty depressing so I guess I
don't need to keep looking at examples
we all know that she's a demon
but I hope that she suffers greatly in
jail actually
although
on one hand I don't think you know just
her
I know jail shouldn't be as awful as it
is in America
but let's say this I hope she really
hates having her kids and freedom taken
from her about that
and that uh
she frequently stubs her toe
that's brutal man careful
and that she has a button that there's a
guard there that Makes Her Go lights out
early I hope the floor's sticky in it
herself sticky ass floor dude
yeah gross psycho that'd be kind of be
kind of baller if the guard just kept it
sticky all the time because he's a fan
how's the floor in there a little sticky
today smelling any pineapple
perpetually pranking eight passenger mom
yeah it's pretty sad she's just evil I
mean there's really no other two ways
about it horrible I mean at least Joe
Jackson he taught his kids to to sing
and dance sing and dance like nobody
else she's just mad for no reason
although it did not work out so great
for Michael in terms of like uh
you know everything there seemed to be
Corruptions everything about his life
really slight amount of psychological
damage with Michael Jackson yes can we
agree on that uh uh yeah yeah yeah I
think that's fair that's fair
the other stuff will will leave out for
now
you know yeah right right right right
right
yep you know what I'm talking right yeah
you know
uh-huh
good point though
so I mean
I I look forward to just kind of seeing
what happens to her I look forward to
seeing learning more about the dad's
involvement about her business partner's
involvement and all this kind of stuff
and I hope that these kids are able to
find
a good healthy environment where they
can you know begin to
deprogram their damaged little Minds
from their psychotic mom you know
under father's fatherly care which
sounds creepy
under Daddy's fatherly care
I don't like it don't like it
let's see um
oh God so EDP caught again
that's crazy
also it's super weird it was a
William
so we'll talk about that Burning Man was
a disaster oh there's so much stuff to
talk about so I love the Starfield
pronoun drama too I love it oh it's
great it was also good so what do you
guys want to hear maybe y'all are are
burned out on transphobic freaks
uh but it is pretty fun to make fun of
them because they're just so dumb but
that's such a goofball he's such a
goofball I he like I had never heard of
this guy and after looking at his
channel and everything he's um he's
British quartering like in every way
right you know what I did this morning
is I went on his channel and I searched
for videos with Brie Larson in the title
and he has so many no way
yeah I'm telling you and I'm embarrassed
to admit I used to watch this guy a lot
because back in the days he was at
completely normal World of Warcraft
content creator without any politics is
he popular he was very popular one of
the biggest really back in the days yeah
oh they I don't know very big and it's
so bizarre to see him like freak out
about this yeah well and Jeremy used to
be a magic guy right right yeah no he
would no no Jeremy was a game
claw machine man yeah and if you are
kids that sent your dress to and he
would mail you his prizes yeah that's
awesome
so this guy
there's this we talked about it a bit
Starfield you choose your pronouns at
the beginning of the game I didn't even
notice it it's so slight when I made my
character you literally it's something
that you've done in video games
basically for the best decade or two you
decide your pronouns you decide your
gender
you decide your pronouns and he has a
complete meltdown
um over it
by the way the top comment he's not
alone the top comment is right
on oh yeah passion and wrath made my day
and fully so many of my internal
thoughts from the last couple of years
where I thought I was just being
hypersensitive nice to know I'm not
alone
but the good news is this guy's being
pretty much universally clowned for for
this which is good
but watch this watch this I mean it's
it's yeah exactly
taking my headphones off that oh
there is nothing seriously I love more
than to to sit down comfy chat
turn on a piece
PCG uh Lose Myself think oh my God just
think of this world just think of all
the planets I can visit can I say this
joke
oh boy
[Music]
thank you foreign
I didn't even say anything you did
oh because I said what it means yes
so I can't say that joke not even close
radioactive okay I mean it's funny
though right you got some laughs like if
me and you were hanging out and I said
that sure okay off the air
off the air it's pretty funny
okay I wasn't sure you guys react but
apparently it was a really bad one yeah
all right keep causing you clear dude
that's impossible is it really yeah well
I'm confused why we bought on that did
you explain it yeah
let's move on let's move on okay no we
don't need to move on but I said too
much all right said too much who would
get angry him or like the conservatives
I everyone really everyone yeah yeah
too much okay all right back it up
that's a golden goblin moment
that's awesome
I think it's funny
but I'm glad I asked anyway continue my
friend
all the immersive things that I can get
involved with all the fights all the
relationships all the people I meet all
the places I go I'm so excited to go
there and you know I love nothing more
then with all of that laid out in front
of me I love nothing more than to be
dragged out and every
conceivable opportunity so you can
Karen Deus
so you can okay so before I continue
do we have a clip of
this moment he's talking about where
they ask like like it's so minor it's so
insignificant
yeah yeah I would like to show exactly
what he's he's um
getting fully triggered about upset
about yeah
okay sorry did you want to get immersed
in our world yeah well guess what
pronouns sorry to tell you bro
but the future is going to be full of
pronouns and the past yeah I did
everything get used to it brother
we're living in a pronoun heaven
let's see here's the Creator
creation
um and there's like a ton of things you
can customize right
so it says
so like I I guess did it even ask him to
change it it just says he him yeah I
think it probably just defaults to that
if you pick uh body type and then if you
want to change it you can so it's not
even like I think it's just the fact
that it says he him it was especially
triggering because that's like that's
that's the woke way of having it in your
Twitter bio or whatever and I believe
you can choose they them too as an
option too
I can't emphasize
how minor part this was in the creation
character creation process yeah it seems
like like you said you wouldn't even
like you could just hit I didn't notice
it except didn't notice it like you
wouldn't even know it's literally just
there for people that care
this is a nice it's a nice it's just for
people that that want to have that
option right anyone else it's basically
invisible too yeah you know what it
probably has reactivity in the game as
far as like how other characters address
you or whatever yeah yeah it makes sense
to have that right I bet it's not even
that because they wouldn't do usually
they're so ambiguous what's called like
they don't yeah when they're talking
about here in that way yeah hold on
right Ian thank you this is perfect this
is someone doing it here
but here they're doing their character
creation you type the name of your
character
and then okay make ice and fire wasn't
good well you got wow that's it oh my
God
they ruined current Deus like current
date do you think that the game is the
problem or do you think you're the
problem because you say every single
turn I'm getting current Dade but like
are you
I mean stop living in the past bro
we live in the current look at this man
I mean again I didn't I did not even
notice it right see how fast
I'm so fast up
so it's it's good to know the context
with what she's freaking the out
it's helpful one thing I will say that I
love about Starfield so far it's the
only game I've ever played where it says
your name so I did Teddy because I was
playing with my son and so they refer to
me as they can say my name in the game
Captain Teddy oh that's pretty cool
that's sick of that that's sick whoa
what yeah they say the name how does
that how does it do that use like an AI
yeah it must be yeah oh but they say my
name in the game is that cool
that is really cool first time I've seen
them because all the games I've always
kind of got stuck on that they always
like oh the champion is here but the
hero is here yeah he goes good there's
like a robot on your butt on your ship
good good afternoon Captain Teddy sounds
great too this is there is no AI a
pre-recorded list of set names yeah
thousands and thousands of names yeah
whoa I thought it was cool I had never
seen that I thought awesome
so if you do like super cool I'm just
I've kind of Blown Away that it does
that if you do poop Feast 420 it
probably will not right yeah
that's probably why they made that guy
change his name
the example we just it was just two
letters that's what happened it was like
MK or something
so I can't be a b
people saying Fallout 4 had it too I
didn't remember that probably because I
never used a normal name exactly and
mine was probably something crazy too so
all right so anyway continue my friend
in Your Righteous uh indignation
so we know cause we're boring
we're so boring yeah can you
play the clown music and the honking and
stuff thanks
you tell them
we can't see past our own
reflection oh he's getting deeper the
level of our narcissism go ahead Zach
I'll wait for it my shit's glitching out
hold on one second I thought this Reddit
post was kind of fun you want to keep
playing it I'll pipe it in real quick
wow I'll wait for you AB found the
the list what a surprise
abdullah's not on there that sucks Dan
Daniel and Danny and Daniel what is this
I just thought it was funny that his
face kind of looks normal looks the same
upside down
yeah
that is interesting isn't it yeah well
the good you know he's probably already
got job offers from The Blaze the daily
wire they're all coming for him you know
Rumble gave him an exclusive contract
they love it
can you go on more rants like that all
right thank you Zach here we go so this
this is more accurate I'm
reflection
that's the level of our gnosticism here
in Bethesda Western game company
go on your emotion you having
a good time you falling into a
world
current day
[Music]
off
boring you dough
one hived mind waffle
hahaha that's all you are
any wonder why people are getting so
sick and tired you take
everything we love all our emotions all
our fantasies
[Music]
crap ideology into everything
every single surgery thing
wow
well you got the sample clients
laughs
all right
well done man
talk about virtue signaling I didn't
make it all the way to the end of the
video because I just bailed it was too
cringe and
that in there I mean with that Antics I
think hopefully we made it more fun
but man that guy sucks huh yeah
his precious immersion though he's not
immersed anymore you're not even in the
game yet yeah
and also there's like a million other
things that break immersion more like
like the best game there's people
walking through the concrete and like
their heads are falling I'm walking
around with like a literally like 10 000
pounds of
do you want to talk about pronouns
breaking immersion
down
stop it I'm traveling at light speed
brother that's impossible according to
the laws of physics
you know what I mean
how am I going to travel from one star
system to another with no change in time
no time explain that how how do
they do that even theoretically when you
can time travel there's an there's an
incredible passage of or I mean can
travel at light speed there's an
incredible passage of time that doesn't
happen in the game explain that that's a
good point dumbass when you're uh
when you're walking around your
spaceship where's the gravity coming
from
no they explained that they have gravity
generators of course yeah of course they
do no that one how do they work though
oh they didn't we didn't get into the
science of it
but you know the pronouns is really the
most inexplicable uh gender immersive
Breaking Point yeah
and what's funny is it just said he him
because he made a guy and again if it
just yeah if it wasn't formatted like
that I feel like it wouldn't have even
caught his eye it's just because he
hates people on Twitter or whatever and
they they have pronounselves I bet he
still played it too dumbass he did he's
like all right anyway let's continue on
okay so I'm starting and I've got 10
I've got 20 000 pounds of of uh of
spaceship Goods on me okay let's go
ahead and proceed to the next location
by foot
but a loser I hope he feels dumb
although I'm sure he doesn't he doesn't
and there's like a whole um
there's been kind of like a uh Mount
Rushmore of transphobic idiots lately
there's one from Jake Paul and there's
one from the doc and there's one from
our very uh beloved Rob Schneider of all
Schneider well the doc one is related to
this so let me open the doc one first
the doc who is 42 apparently
oh you're younger than you
or actually wait how old is he someone
someone looked that up real fast
uh respect p is 41 41. what an old
losers time to get a real job
either
please put down the wig man the gig is
up
so okay it took me a minute to
understand what was happening so here
he is in the uh
one of the lead um the head of
publishing head of publishing for
Bethesda
in his Twitter description it says he
slash him
he's trying to understand why they
wouldn't pay him to play their wildly
popular popular and vastly already a
marketed game I don't think it was even
pay him I think it was just give him an
advanced copy well he asked for both he
asked for both
so he sees it said he him in the
description and then that's what
triggers this whole response
[Music]
it's starting to make sense now
yep everything's starting to make sense
got it we got it we got him that makes
sense
I got it got it so I gotta say this
chance for just real quick
brother obviously we've been hyping up
Star Citizen for uh uh star field
for a long time
and we've been making it very vocal
right chips uh sounds like you've been
already doing all the work for them
dummy
we had our team reach out hey can we
work with you can we do something
due to the Past controversies there's
maybe we can work with uh Dr disrespect
by the way I talked about this gesture
on the members but as someone who has a
has controversies like I never get angry
that somebody doesn't want to work with
me for being a controversial YouTuber
like come on bro you did the you
did just own it and try to do
you want to be better and change
or do you want to just like
keep being the same
the reason why they didn't want to work
with you
which uh which
incident do you think caused him to not
thought sponsors anymore was it the
recording children in in a bathroom
again without their knowledge well I've
heard I've heard he sheets in games so
stuff like that
it could have been one of those or well
I I think he has done more transphobic
stuff first I don't know I'm not really
following his career anymore well he was
uh backing up that Nick Merks guy uh
when they recently oh yeah what was that
it was another Call of Duty gamer mad
about something it was the protest in
Glendale I believe about oh right yeah
right yeah it wasn't even like a game
thing it was remember there was like the
uh brawl that happened in a school board
meeting uh here in Glendale
you remember what I'm talking about
yeah what did he say he said yeah yeah
like a take on it that um he was Pro the
parents yeah he was Pro the people
beating up people
so yeah so I mean listen you also it's
like it's so nice of you to have this
privilege where you work by yourself in
such a vacuum Bethesda probably employs
like 10 000 people maybe and you know
they are they're gonna be inclusive for
all their employees to have a harmonious
healthy working environment so it's nice
for you to sit there and be like
pronouns what kind of a loser
it's like go outside and actually see
talk and work with some people bro like
try saying that out in public at a
job and see how cool you are there
you're a giant loser
you are a giant
regressive loser
you're a 41 year old with the wig on man
take it off just be yourself dude I'm
over the dock character it's been long
enough time to move on yeah
you know what I mean
come on bro
did you the girl the young fan in
the wig or did you take it off
no be yourself
that's what I'm saying
[Music]
we got him
how about just give me
like let me play the game when it when
when some of the others are playing it
how about that
yeah it's still that's still
still the case
well it's there's not really a
difference they don't want us to be seen
as you know collaborating with you
because
they don't like
the you do brother
kind of a big douche
anyways chance we just we just had to
get that go ahead and just shut the
up and play the game now loser
after all the virtue signaling
grandstanding yeah they're all gonna
play it
stupid ass right yeah take a fast don't
play it so that was Dr disrespect uh on
the heels of this uh horrible pronoun
controversy Jake Paul
you know this one surprised me I felt
the Paul brothers were at least Savvy
Savvy enough to not
be this outwardly dumb
uh about social issues but Jake is
I don't think so
well here he is Logan maybe yeah maybe
Logan's a lot more Savvy about it Jake I
don't think gives a I think I think
Logan went through extensive sensitivity
training yeah
yeah so as you can see he's in Good
Company Aiden Ross and sneako and what
is the first question they ask everybody
who comes hangs out with them only the
most pertinent thing a person can know
yeah Jake how many genders are there uh
there's three
male female and mentally ill
but yeah the antille ill is not a gender
bro it doesn't make sense as a joke nice
try
there's actually five male female the
hungry the thirsty
the meek
and people who really like ice cream
I don't know
yeah it's like dude nice joke for
12 year olds
he for sure heard his dad say that joke
or someone his friend dad is friends
with or something
yeah Jake how many genders are there hey
bro before we kick it I gotta ask you
how many genders are there I've got to
see if you passed the test
and yet somehow
it's the libs who are obsessed
the gender issue
the pronoun issue Ada is so goofy
God he really is such a dumbass just
look at him yeah
three
male female
dude yeah
yeah yeah what about intersex
can we give a carve out for the intersex
folks out there
red pill report says Jake nailed it
thank you cool
six likes Jill Biden a parody account
actually no there are Six Trillion
genders buddy get it right
wow Jill Biden she's spit
hilarious right there brother it's
brutal
the really only asked people are really
only asking to just add like they
not 6 trillion
it's just one more
than you're used to
you know
it's not that serious also uh Rob
Schneider
who am shocked to see with a bad take uh
especially after we spoke so highly of
his uh Netflix show the real Rob
truly one of the most bizarre and
terrible shows I've ever seen I watched
it just out of utter horror and uh and
uh morbid curiosity yeah but you won't
slow down there Zach I'm sorry this is
insane he's a piece of but no that
shows quality wait you're a fan yeah I'm
a real rock you should not admit that
yeah what are you doing great dude that
show is so dumb it's like such a
wannabe curb but with no Talent no
Charisma his character has it is
literally just a giant hassle like he
has no redeeming qualities and he
parades his real wife in the character
right always putting his real wife who's
some I guess Mexican super young model
and she is always in like really weird
compromising positions because in the
show
she's also trying to be an actress and
so she's like
it's bro it sounds like you know more
about the show that he said he was well
I watched it what do we want
I'm telling you Rob Schneider is a demon
he he's a piece of I used to like
the guy but um yeah me too me too I like
it yeah back in the days when I was like
12. I saw like Adam Sandler and his
whole gas like I'm in for a treat today
right but nowadays they kind of fell off
dude the other thing about that show the
man put an entire blue tint to all the
footage so that his blue eyes popped
tomorrow I would do that I swear to you
the whole show is blue
it's so bizarre I dismissed when he was
in the background of Adam Sandler's
movies just saying you can do it that's
all I wanted yeah go back to that you
ever needed from Russia even that's too
much is he Handler boot him
[Music]
he was in Just Go With It which is like
yeah you know what I gotta I gotta say
something I've been seeing a lot of this
since this Rob Schneider thing uh of
like oh Adam Sandler Adam Sandler should
disavow him or whatever their best
friend you think that Adam
Sandler doesn't think all of these same
things
like oh you can't you can't yes you
can't make bad connection I'm Sandler
okay what well why with on what what
basis
I think he just keeps his opinions to
himself well maybe that's smarter Rob
yeah just shut the up
maybe you better stick to acting
Sandler's also conservative is that
right
is he actually I mean I just read that's
just a chat comment
did you guys hear about the teddy fresh
and his new Netflix movie
oh that was great I love Adam Sandler
no he's super talented and I'll tell you
what man Jack and Jill is one of the
best time movies of all time I've never
done a bad movie Don Cachino dude he's
never done a bad movie 50 First Dates
what an actor
that Adam Sandler is
um yeah apparently they
they had some Teddy fresh and his new
movie
that's pretty cool I thought
you are so not want invited to my bad
Mitzvah I actually watched it was pretty
enjoyable
cool wait people are saying that Adam
Sandler Matt was a maxed out donator to
Rudy Giuliani
Oh you mean like when he was running for
mayor yes yeah but that's a different
time you know he likes he put Rudy
people like her man yeah dude people
liked Rudy Giuliani Rudy was inside yeah
Republicans yeah Rudy was in Seinfeld
everybody rallied around Rudy he's the
he's America's mayor dude um
anyway here's what Rob Schneider said
about um
uh Dylan Mulvaney
he said
if you believe there is such a thing as
cultural appropriation
then certainly this gentleman
is guilty of gender appropriation
yikes Rob
you did a movie
where you turned into a woman that was
the entire premise of the movie
and to eat dinner you're not the guy to
make that argument it's a dog
argument anyways but if you're trying to
make like the appropriate like you you
appropriated being a woman for a movie
literally the hot chick the hot chick
they also did a movie where he turned
into an animal too
but it's just
ins like how how how did he not think
about this
um let's see here Rob uh here you are in
a
let's see he's in a dress here he is
with the girlies
God look at his blue eyes he's doing it
here too he made them brighten his eyes
didn't he yeah he for sure did like they
have like hold on
oh my God Rachel McAdams and Anna Faris
were in this movie and she has blue eyes
she has blue eyes why isn't her shining
like a brilliant Emerald
are we quiet
it's a better highlight
um but let I guess I'll I'll bite I'll
try to analyze this statement real Rob
season three January 6th no no no no I'm
making a joke oh thank God
two seasons was nuts I do recommend
people who to go watch it just it's such
a
spectacle man season three comes out
January 6th
we watched a few scenes did those get
claimed I remember back in the day I
believe so yeah here's a a screen grab
though if you want to show the blue tint
here's a scree grab oh yeah look at this
his whole show every episode frame for
frame looked like this you see how
washed out and blue it is for what
reason I bet you identified the reason
that's so weird
um all right let's uh let's break this
down then Robbie since it is apparently
a uh deep
a deep deep uh first of all love the uh
misgendering on purpose
so cultural so the idea of cultural
appropriation
is like super nuanced I feel like
you know
it's not my place to say really because
I'm not really from any kind of culture
that has been appropriate I don't think
you even need to do that because
obviously Rob like Rob Schneider isn't
making that argument in good faith he
doesn't believe that cultural
appropriation is a thing or a problem
have you seen the Arab Duty plays in the
Zohan exactly
way too much credit he's trying to say
oh well Libs if you care about cultural
appropriation then why don't you care
about gender appropriation
you know
but
does does do trans people take away from
the entire identity of Womanhood no are
they using this idea of Womanhood that's
been like
it's part of like a history and
uniqueness of like a whole group of
people like I'm a woman this is this is
who I am I've been I've grown up I've
learned what a woman is I've been
through it all
because these are my people being a
woman isn't a monolith that is that is a
nebulous constantly shifting thing that
depends on a million factors of culture
and times and time and everything and so
so no
I think Rob Schneider
um is equipped to to talk about what's
what it is to be a woman
I think that he probably would be
perfect for the job to talk Justice
as a woman myself yeah let me say this
is gender all I'm saying is once you
become a Fox News comic it's a game over
bro it's game over was he doing that
route he's got a thing on the for the
Fox Nation or whatever it's called oh
yeah that that's death that is well
that's death they take like the worst
Comedians and revive them because you
can't find any damn good comedian who's
gonna go do right wing stick well they
do have Roseanne they have Roseanne they
have that dumb from uh how uh uh
the Dave Chappelle movie of Jim Brewer
yeah Jim Brewer
a maniac he used to be so good too
because he did a bunch of on Howard
all the time but um he's just a
idiot now
he got he got coveted brained
I haven't liked Rob Schneider since what
he did the Howie
when he said oh yeah that was fun that
was
he did Howard he did Howie wrong man
can I open this is this gonna get
claimed was he the one I think you could
show I I just like a sec maybe he did
how he's so wrong for this
yeah I might get claimed so oh my God
it's nice to see you oh boy
this is so
this is a caring man right here
can I say though at least a little bit
Rob's defense here maybe not the best
gig for Highway to be a talk show host
right well I mean
Uncle Howie he probably thought every
guest would be would have some respect
for the host they probably they probably
briefed them ahead of time like hey
please don't shake Howie's hand he has
OCD yeah and so Rob was like I'm gonna
have to go out of your way to be a
douche about it which he did no no no
but like you know the talk show you're
shaking hands you're saying hi you're
hugging it's a very kind of you know
it's all right but I get I imagine in
99.9 of cases of people that went on
that show
a stage manager was like oh yeah just a
reminder don't shake his hand it's like
oh yeah I won't do that and that's it
it's pretty easy to overcome they'd be
like no as long as you're not Rob
Schneider and you're not like no
that show us
show us what
amen
well anyway you know I love Howie I
would never do a single thing to
to uh I mean he we must cherish him and
Rob Schneider you get shame on shame on
you man
[Music]
so gender appropriation
I'm sorry I just love Rob saying you got
to get over it you got to get over it
man oh is he saying that
wait we gotta pull that because that's
pretty relevant to him
it's like right when you say sit down
yeah yeah French people no no the you
know let me go back I gotta see this
this wisdom from Robbie boy on how to
handle OCD two I get the back you're in
good shape thank you buddy you don't
even understand right now what's going
on in his head no I have no idea
the ladies right there did he say it did
I miss it
I think it was before they hear I'm
finding the exact moment I'm just gonna
I'm gonna go do it all again you guys
foreign
[Music]
that's my favorite uh advice for people
with any with any really any problem
depression anxiety
OCD
takes him a second to get on the stool
because he's under five feet tall
you know even like with with debt with
deaths that were close to you it's good
advice
you know with grief get over it right
can you get Purell yes
what a dick dude
you just you know what are You Afraid of
Anything
are you afraid of anything I actually
have antibacterial gel that I actually
use that too
you're in good shape thank you buddy you
don't even understand right now what's
going on in his head no I have no idea I
don't care think oh oh look the lady's
right there and the second row has
antiseptic wipes throw it throw it throw
it away
I got some right here it's okay
there we go
that was a good throw down
no problem
no he's the worst
yeah he sucks Jesus so anyway sorry
Dylan uh Mulvaney that you have to go
through all these psychos targeting you
for no reason
it's because you're on a beer can damn
who's this Zack this is a Jeff Tate the
lead singer for Queensryche oh my God
and what about this looks like Howie
okay not at all I didn't say it
literally zero it's just too random but
hold on I have another Are You Gonna
Play that video that's a real guy
I thought he looks like the villain from
the command and Conquer video game
series
um that could be Howie right there
all right thank you everybody throw that
out there
so that's that shout out to uh the Mount
Rushmore of transphobic morons today
you know I like calling these people out
because it's like
they're so privileged dude look at his
eyes oh my God look at Rob that's how we
that's how he presents him some to the
world you didn't even blew those I know
it
look at these guys love them there is
only two genders we're marching on
Washington
these libs are talking about gender and
trans people too much so we started an
organization
we're going to dedicate 40 hours per
week to it
we'll organizes marches every week
to like transphobic Power Rangers
oh
it's awesome I'm closer
candies why do you just leave him alone
y'all
weird All Right Moving On
uh so we have to talk about EDP and
burning man still God I am
where's that food at though for real oh
I was just thinking that I'm hungry
you know what I'm saying
no one's we have like 15 minutes
let's see what is this
oh God what does that mean we have 15
minutes well technically I'm supposed to
end the show in 15 minutes but that's oh
you have to leave at 4 30. oh no no I
don't know that's my target time okay
okay that throws a lot into disarray let
me tell you
[Music]
prick what is there something I missed
about that yeah
the EDP thing we haven't talked about
yet we have to talk it's like the second
thing in the title all right so EDP as
you guys know eat that it stands
for oh yeah um
an old contributor to our show I've
often
funny to remember that eh yeah it used
to be the back in the days it used
to be I thought he was so funny yeah I
was like this guy is nuts yeah like in a
funny way yeah
eat that uh four four pounds
wasn't expecting those words to come out
of your mouth that's his name that's
what that's what EDP stands for that's
crazy yeah it is it's pretty crazy you
just threw me off guard uh he was caught
trying to meet a
okay so previously this was a huge story
we didn't really touch on he was
previously caught trying to meet up with
a 13 year old
it was of course orchestrated by
vigilante sting operation he was 30
years 30 years old at the time he had 2
million subscribers
he was actually doing quite well he was
getting more and more attention
but uh he is his excuse was I was just
going to get some cupcakes and then go
home which is turned into an iconic and
fist bump fist bump and a cupcake so
they have the logs of him being you know
sexual with her and stuff yeah
and so since then
his life and career has absolutely
cratered as you can imagine surprise
surprise
I heard he was even trying to get like
regular jobs and people were just
calling and
sharing all the story like he he
couldn't he couldn't
do basic functions of his life
although I have seen videos of him going
viral on Tick Tock since that people are
just like yeah that's EDP yeah
he had a video of him like eating a
cupcake and making a joke about it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
do we have that he got banned off Tick
Tock so so people were with him
because he was just like yeah dude I'm a
pedo what's up
yeah it was him eating a cupcake
and people are like you yeah let's go
EDP
it had like it had so many views and
likes
I was flabbergasted oh here's a
re-upload of it
yeah this had hundreds of thousands of
likes on tick tock
that's our boy
he got his cupcake y'all
anyway I gotta go I'm on my way to meet
another 12 year old
Jesus Christ so
there's like an addition he sent like a
picture of his to the dick oh God
yeah in the toilet I remember that yeah
why did he do that just like shake this
I sent her a picture of his
yeah toilet two two Romance
[Music]
here just he sent a dump
in a toilet
to a child that's right crazy so
uh okay so anyway years after the
notorious cupcake incident Gideon a
wittian as we call him confronted EDP
445 about those events with the full
video on the topic promising to shed
light on his activities
since he was banned from YouTube
so wait this video is not out yet so
what he meets up with EDP yeah he posted
a clip on his uh on his take to on
Gideon's Tick Tock right here so here
apparently they got him again
but I'm confused about the timeline was
he making a documentary with him and
then this happened or was this part of
the stand like I don't get it so so
there is a recap under the the clips and
the dog okay here let me read this
um
jadian contacted ADP for an interview of
course why not you know I mean let's hey
we can make a few bucks off this pedal
let's bring him on EDP wanted to be paid
for the interview
Gideon said no okay fair despite being
rejected EDP joined Gideon's Discord
server and started dming with a 15 year
old girl there in Gideon's Community
yeah he sent the girl dick pics Gideon
has a whole chat log of him being creep
with this girl that's kind of on you bro
so as you literally invited him into
your community
what what could happen if I invite this
pedophile onto my show to interview him
so I hadn't thought of that he kind of
it's not that point he kind of mentioned
it Gideon said that he was kind of the
concert yeah he feels like that I
up to his okay I'm glad that he
recognizes that that was probably not a
good move that's why some people even
though you know it's going to be views
it's just maybe not always yeah
worth the uh
the combo Jeanine says that EDP was
trying to meet up with the girl on her
16th birthday in Nevada 16 is the age of
consent in Nevada 16 is the age of
consent
keemstar was coaching him oh God jadian
caught wind of this spoke with the girl
and her parents law enforcement well so
wait was okay law enforcement is
involved investigating the crime as well
Jaden said he might go back to court
with this girl jadian in another to
catch a predator-style YouTuber Skeeter
Gene confronted him outside his dialysis
center yeah
that's a hell of a place to Blitz
someone
does he have kidney failure uh yes
remember I think he's I think he's quite
ill actually
too many cupcakes might not be long for
the world is this related to like he has
severe diabetes okay so too many okay
too many fudge rounds
uh this is this is just what Oliver
Anthony was warning us about
it looks like he's lost weight frankly
in this though
uh
uh Skeeter Gene is
um
oh Skeeter Gene is in chat interesting
yeah he's saying yo hopefully okay
what's up hopefully you're not like the
last dude because that guy was a weirdo
but if you're in this chat you probably
rule
the first guy who caught him was a real
weirdo the guy who made the cupcake
video himself
ended up having what what was it was it
actually I think he was also doing stuff
I don't want to speak out of terms
remember that something happened with
that it was yeah
what's up skater Gene thank you brother
thank you for your work brother
Skeeter Gene you a legend
he has 800 000 Subs
how many 800k Skeeter G you're a legend
thank you for your work brother send me
his channel let me pick it up
okay
Moreland yeah this guy uh the guy who
caught him the first time not Skeeter
Gene the legend Bryant Moreland bro you
literally said to Skeet a predator
isn't that mean to come on them yes
yeah that is what that means
professional Chris Hanson impersonator
cookies for you yo you're skeeting on
Predators I guess in a sense that's
tasted their own medicine all right
fighting fire or fire
um
yeah this previous guy the more Moreland
uh
was previously accused of talking to
underage girls dude that's so gnarly so
not Skeeter though Skeeters are boy some
of these are wild Skeeter I'm gonna sub
because I I'm gonna watch these vids I I
was unaware of your punk band but I mean
the titles are pretty wild 30 year old
man brings contraceptives for a 14 year
old girl
Predator lies his ass off for 30 minutes
and claims his baby monama set him up
did you bring condoms
I'll just click one real fast
I wonder what I don't know what Skeeter
looks like
okay these videos are so freaking wild
oh is this isn't like a real cup it's
like a bounty hunter type of situation
yeah probably or just security security
which yeah is like that's always my
concern with these
uh you know amateur pedo hunter ambushes
or whatever is these guys have nothing
to lose in that moment exactly but like
weirdly it it doesn't seem to happen and
I don't know if it's like
the type of like psychological profile
of these people because like on the
Chris Hansen show too they would always
just like kind of shut down and like
just become super um docile right
exactly obedient right so like I I guess
most of the time it's probably fine but
you'd think like you said like they got
nothing to lose at the point I'm
surprised it doesn't turn violent I
think in their minds they think like
if I cooperate I can maybe win him over
and we can come to some agreement that's
exactly it because they don't they don't
know the cops are behind the door you
know when like Chris says oh you can
leave like let's figure this out dude
I'll be totally honest with you Skeeter
said that dudes his security oh yeah
that's smart
okay brother I gotta hold you down now
it's time to do the skeeting
I don't think sorry
in person like all right now
right if your gut feeling was telling
you not to do it then why'd you keep
going I don't know why I walked in here
I should have just went like yeah no
never mind I'm done I don't want to do
this
kind of true I really really I like your
voice Skeeter and you know what you guys
would just let me go home and you know
nothing's coming and
hey Nick not to mention you could have
potentially you know are you trying to
sound like Chris Hanson or is that just
the vibe he sounds I just like him to me
it sounds like he's trying to do a
chriso too that was his uh profile it
says professional Chris Hansen in person
I'm Chris Hanson with daylight all right
oh no way anything let's go
let's go sorry Alfredo this is a
perfectly spiced french fry no way I got
French fries too no way no way
ketchup
thank you dude the crisp was crazy
foreign
I got a club sandwich holy moly somebody
donated uh two bucks and said EDP was I
am I aming
I am I haven't heard the phrase I am in
a long time EDP was iming my uh high
school girlfriend like seven years ago
yeah it seems like he's busy yeah it
seems like he was doing this to a lot of
people
dude I'm gonna hit some shalua on this
so sure can't wait
um shout out Skeeter
he's just said uh thanks Poppy I like
yours too
oh thank you brother about your the
voice I assume yeah team Skeeter
team skeet that's actually the name of
those are the people that said my dad
yeah oh yeah yeah that's why I said it
team Skeeter I'm not team skied I'm team
smash that one
that's funny
anyway here's the rest of the video
[Music]
two years ago
it's awesome
by the way that's a witty in moment EDP
is so like he's he's been through this
he's like bro I don't care not again
he's straight up like suck suck it I
don't care
and yeah this was in front of his
dialysis jeez I guess that's a good
place to catch someone what are they
gonna do not go to dialysis right
good point it's made sense you know
oh man
that's crazy
yeah it's a little crazy
this is not a joke man I missed
for words you know two years ago you
were kissed my ass kiss my ass yeah I'm
not talking to you
he really has a problem
that's crazy yeah
he couldn't even help himself Jillian's
like yo let's do an interview
he said cool I'm gonna come try to
prey on your fans real fast and discard
um
so I guess the video is forthcoming
it was worth coming
um
here's another clip of EDP staying up
going around
let's check it out
new footage dropped
bro you still straight Chris dancing
that's funny so spot on it's crazy
oh man
eat that predator
[Music]
like this Brian I just have a few
questions I want to know what this
picture is of you with the makeup on do
you recall this picture Bryant
oh Brian can you look here I just want
to know what this is interesting like
what in the actual is this right
if you could guess what do you think
we're here
could you could you answer me that
Bryant
Brian
the dialysis people will be like oh
you're back yeah I think I need a little
more dialogue like this Brian I just
have a few questions please
oh yeah
you gotta see the photo Ethan I think
you missed it when it popped up of him
with makeup yeah do you see it yeah
do you recall this picture Brian
[Laughter]
why did he do that I'd love to know the
context of that bro they probably took
over the shot and with him or
something no oh yeah they're humiliated
yeah that would be my guess that's six
I'm so excited for this video dude
sorry guys I'm starving
you're suggesting that they took over as
the girl I mean I'm just guessing yeah
that's a good guess
can you look here I just want to know
what this is
what in the actual is this like
Brian
scooter
all right I'm gonna watch it I'm curious
it
that's so fun
so he's really dying that's pretty wild
just from kidney failure from diabetes
I think I think so
um
it wasn't somebody backed me up here I
feel like yes yeah yeah yeah like yeah
that's like a known thing about him
right but how old is he he's pretty
young
I think it's in mid-30s
31 or 32. eat that insulin four four
five
I feel bad from him you know this is a
up thought but do you think like
if he thinks he's dying this is like his
last ride he's like I'm on my way out
anyways because I'm like watching this
I'm like how could he be that
stupid to do it again
well his life is already fully ruined
like he he already has no nothing to
lose pretty much
and if he's dying even less yeah
this is his Breaking Bad
God
no
he can't get no I I think that's
seriously
that seriously something to factor in
this dude is dangerous he's dying he's
on the loose
he's gonna be doing some he's like
Batman he doesn't fear death yeah
dude I cannot believe he got cupcaked
what a cupcake
I need to wearing pants that says raw
Doggett can we get the messaging uh
here who are we raw dogging I need some
Twitter notes on this remember we went
through this with him he's raw dog in
life right oh we asked him that
I I think okay does that mean he doesn't
quite remember does that mean he doesn't
have health insurance what does that
mean he's a professional raw dog or this
is just a professional raw doctor dude
it's ragdog in life okay
self-explanatory
it is really sad honestly because he was
really a funny funny wild wild character
you know
I mean he had a lot of fans a lot of
supporters some of the funniest
I've ever seen on YouTube I think but
it's
disgusting you know
oh yeah
so let's see
um
here's a link to the interview
uh Gideon uh did an interview with um
with uh
before he even put the video out correct
and the summary uh that's above is is
the interview from um wow so he we're
doing a lot of press here yeah
for the cupcake tour
an additional circumstance ADP thought
he was doing a Discord interview with
people
Gideon disguised himself and used the
name EDP lover
and then proceeded to surprise EDP on
the call
link to the clip
that you're passionate about that other
people can't do you know what I mean at
your level you know what I mean they
start making up and they start
trying to make your life as miserable as
they possibly can and that's what and
that's basically all this is dude I
mean you know
a jealousy you know what I mean
um
jealousy
this man is literally I don't think he
can lose more
baby I mean we purchase that's what he
does what's up Brian
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you're God
did he bail you just turned it off
[Laughter]
version of the ketchup
so wait this video has been a long time
in the making I guess
that's my understanding yeah he didn't
even want to post to this earlier from
my understanding he wants to wait till
he got arrested but something got leaked
he explained so he decided to just post
it now that's from what I understand
watching he uh Gideon said he prepared
the hell hold on to this for about a
year until uh you know was figured
out legally that's weird yeah
I wonder if the police told him the way
um
there it is that is uh
EDP and gidium
a collab you might say
they did a collab together
how's the food
amazing
[Music]
so I go to California
um and it's Boston and the fries the
chipotle sauce whatever that is I'm
hitting the the Cholula life is
beautiful that's beautiful can I borrow
some of that real quick look yeah I'm
gonna come over there real quick real
quick uh Skeeter said we caught him like
a month ago
okay
really a month so have you guys just
been sitting on her or have you all been
like editing and
[Music]
yeah in the laboratory
all right I mean I'll give him a witty
in for this you know
go give him the widian
although
if anyone got the dub it was obviously
Skeeter
he did all the heavy lifting
he did the voice yeah all right let's
talk about burning man then
we've done it all
I gotta say the um the club sandwich
not the best club sandwich I've ever had
very soft
regret I feel like there's got to be
textures it's just very soft the whole
thing
stuff kind of caught me off guard a
little bit
very soft
you know what I'm saying
Burning Man is over
how do they continue after this year
I've actually been wondering
dude like they might is there a chance
that they lose their permit over this
pretty bad I think so people left so
much dude yeah
people were abandoning like campers
tents trash I mean God knows there's got
to be metric tons of just garbage
literally littering the desert out there
uh but I feel that their their identity
is garbage they're a little confused
Burning Man
who's the man exactly
because of the big statue
it's the Effigy that they burn no I know
but like who what man are we talking
about because I don't think it's a
specific man I think it's more the man
Mr is one keeping help hunk of
that have to do with anything
the man that they're burning seems to be
attending the festival uh more and more
every year I see what you're getting huh
like it is the hot spot for
NorCal silicon freaks
and influencers from LA and like like
yeah which man are we burning exactly
are we are we gonna I mean if you guys
start burning people alive there that'd
be different story
whenever we talk about burning the witch
you know an era where we used to burn
the witch exactly that area never really
stopped I bet I bet the hardcore goers
probably agree with you they think it's
like been uh well the old heads yeah
yeah I'm sure and not just that
it costs like seventy five hundred
dollars to get a camping spot to go
there
so it's obscenely expensive
you have to have a ton of money and the
ability to take like a bunch of time off
work
to drive to the middle of
nowhere there ain't no poor people at
Burning Man
not one poor person at Burning Man so
who's the man exactly we're burning
I think if we wanted to burn the man we
just blow up the whole damn Festival
which I don't have the technology nor
the determination to do that was a joke
right yes yeah I will say their website
does say they have low income ticket
tickets yeah right dude Burning Man low
income project give me a break
okay let's say you're poor
so how much is the low income ticket uh
that's a lot of money
225 and then you need to have a job
that's flexible enough for you to go
take a week off I know how long Burning
Man is you need a week off
like between the travel out there and
everything and back a means of getting
there this is not a poor man's game
the whole idea of Burning Man is just a
joke the way it's become now I
mean maybe it was interesting when it
started
but it's really just become uh
it seems to me just like just a festival
of heathenism and debauchery for
super rich people to pretend like
they're normal folks and I mean the
people that do the stuff there it's like
so over the top it's so expensive so
intricate the costumes
the sculptures the cars everything is so
over the top
you kind of got to be a millionaire to
be honest
so
I always thought I felt recently that
Burning Man is quite a dumb thing to
begin with takes place in Black Rock
Desert in uh Northwestern Nevada
Burning Man seven days it's
oh it's less than I thought it's uh 575
dollars plus 140 vehicle pass plus fees
five thousand low income tickets for 225
each you have to show proof of financial
hardship
dude you don't need to
I'm sorry but that just seems silly to
me this isn't you know
these aren't essential Services damn
I wonder what's the threshold for that
in order to provide access to the event
to those without Financial Resources to
purchase the tickets at full price for
those who can't afford to contribute
financially we sell a small pool of
tickets for as much as 1400 to help
offset the cost
we also gift thousands of tickets to
volunteers who build the city and make
the event possible
you mean instead of paying them
I wouldn't exactly call that a gift
interesting
so what went wrong is
it rained that's it
um is located in an area that doesn't
get rain
it's a dry lake bed it can absorb water
it's dry as it rained 13
millimeters which is not a lot
yeah
and the whole is enough desert flooded
not even that it just got muddiest
turned the ground into like not quite
quicksand but almost clay yeah like just
sticky
horrible mud everywhere that Friday the
amount of rain was twice the usual
average of September
so which is 13 so I mean yeah
um so they closed roads
right before that the burning of the
Effigy no no are you saying we're not
gonna burn the man
foreign
but that isn't tradition they broke
the rules yo we broke into dishing this
year
in addition somebody died there
according to a report
uh the man was in his 40s but the cause
of death is not known
okay A little party favor there I heard
it was Ebola
Ebola outbreak I was hearing a lot of
Health uh professionals being like do
not step in the mud that has like
deadly bacteria in it
really I think yeah
okay and then they're all just like
caked in it
see I was
good I mean go look into it I'm pretty
sure there's some like horrific bacteria
and viruses in the mud
Burning Man organizer said the death was
unrelated to the weather okay
cause of manner of death is pending
investigation
but drug overdose is suspected okay that
makes sense there's got to be at least
one person that dies of a drug overdose
at Burning Man every year frankly more
probably more
um doctor says burners need to wash off
mud as soon as possible
no
um
it would help if they said why in the
headline here let's see no
I say bacteria to wash to avoid skin
infections skin infection gotcha
yeah so it's a total disaster there
there's 70 000 people stuck
worse I think they're all out was but 70
000 people were stuck
so they do 5 000 low income tickets
and there's like a hundred thousand
attendees
um
hey Brokey come over here man we got
some free for you
they make them wear a badge
low income low income winner
come over here man Scarlet P for poor
so there's a ton of videos I've been
following so let me pull them up
oh God the 41 year old man died after
leaping into the bonfire are you
crazy seriously this is another I heard
about that oh that's in 2017. yeah 41's
not a good not a good age literally I
guess 2017.
yeah well he maybe he was the man he
knew it was his time
it was his Festival
it was the finale
kidding
[Music]
I'm sorry I was just chewing
so
let's pull up some videos
here's the good people at uh
Burning Man
and this bacteria ridden
here they are attempting to continue
partying
looks like fun
oh yeah that's just what they said you
should do
oh God people paid a lot of money for
this experience
look at this hell on Earth man this is
all trash left behind this
we heard that there was a rumor that
Oliver Anthony was there did we confirm
that Dan uh Dan went to the bathroom but
he told me this morning that uh he
claims he was not there okay that would
be pretty Epic
here's another good one
take a look
okay here's an update from burning man
everybody wants to know the conditions
it is
chaos
it has been raining all night so there
was people literally abandoning all of
their belongings so they could hike like
three miles to the nearest road and hope
someone rescues them so much and
again in about an hour and uh no one's
going anywhere no one's coming in no
one's coming out
yeah the Portos are flooded and oh yeah
there's no toilets too they all got
flooded
sewage trucks in here to evacuate them
so it is getting interesting that's for
sure
okay and this mud is so much different
it is so sticky it sticks to itself your
boots become 10 pounds
it's crazy and to top it all off
we learned that Georgie is not
waterproof so I have all my clothes
hanging up
because everything got so I love it um
anytime someone shows up in a burning
man but this is their profession
text CEO billionaire
yeah
so we took a tarp and we wrapped it to
get through the night but
40 year old RV I mean what are you gonna
do your Burn Right
people have tried to drive down the
streets and
some cars have got stuck so they just
left them they left their cars
dude show you what we're doing it's
Saturday and the burn got canceled all
the burns got canceled so everybody's
mad rushing to pack up while we can
while it's not raining so here we are
wrapping up the Tactical Gecko and our
little camp and yeah the party's rocking
did work
people still partying though man you
hear it hell yeah brother what it's all
about we're in the city right now so
you're not seeing like all the cool
stuff it's just roads and camp
but each Camp is you know themed so they
do their own thing we had a little
Grotto and bar set up in here with pole
dancing stage and a dance cage and then
you know obviously the robot will
usually take out to D Playa but you know
what they say uh you don't get the burn
you want you get the burn you need are
you serious bro if you actually
say that they say that man
yeah the burn you needed was to be
abandoned in a muddy hellscape for three
days you really needed that brother
the player that he I think he said
player that's the area where they have
it they call it Playa Playa oh but yeah
they put on their website right here
talking about apply a foot uh this year
from uh stepping in the desert they have
Playa foot yeah plyfoot is a
Milady malady
my lady I
believe
foot because I'm a lady milady
you put some some character into that
live foot is a Milady unique to the
Black Rock Desert caused by Alka uh
Alkali dust that makes up the desert it
is in essence a chemical burn
the most common cause of Playa foot is
exposure of your feet to the desert
floor by not wearing socks and closed
shoes this malady is not serious it is
uncomfortable the good news is that you
may easily care for it yourself
wash your feet
with vinegar
right sure
exactly dry and they all brought vinegar
to burning man
once you get back oh yeah and then apply
a thin layer of antibiotic ointment to
your souls
and then it says to lightly send your
soul with an open flame right
take three tabs of acid quarter shroom
turn the music up
keep your feet covered with socks and
clothes shoes or boots better reducer
will only allow your feet to get worse
continue to wash your feet
a couple times a day
there you go
seek immediate treatment if
you see any signs of infection you
develop a fever your feet becomes your
rash on your face you gotta apply a face
dude
maybe someone I don't know all the
storms kicked up The Alkali dust
couldn't travel over to California some
people in chat are asking about uh Ebola
and that was a fake CDC report
here's Diplo and Chris Rock of all
people
getting a ride out of hell
why are they like Chris Rock
I'm going to okay that Burning Man okay
here is another one looking completely
abandoned
take a look here
checking in from burning man reigning
man
look at this hell dude a Raining Men
this is just I think all the trash
people left behind
you can see every step is just like
sinking in holy dude
so is someone gonna clean this up
yeah I mean the organization presumably
will but I imagine it's going to be a
massive undertaking even more so than
usual and um it's gonna blow everywhere
too for the time yeah uh I think I've
heard that over the years
has been
you know a constant battle with the uh
park services and everything to get
permanent for it oh why do they care
just a big stupid ass pill man yeah
Good Vibes leaves tons of trash in the
desert here's Good Vibes baby
let's go
good morning it is approximately Burning
Man update Sunday at 10 A.M
Sunday morning
here's what we're starting to witness in
Greater frequency a lot of people are
simply picking up what they can carry
and walking all the way back to the main
gate road to meet with pre-arranged
Transportation such as Uber they are
literally just the Ubers or Camp says
the footprint that's going to be a
horrible cleanup mess that could impact
the future of this event it's radical
radical Independence dude people are
leaving everything to grab an Uber
I'm sorry but this shit's this shit's
dumb we got a call out guys
we gotta call this Burning Man it's
just it's so phony too yeah just leave
it in the past
it was fun while it lasted I guess
but I can't take any more
videos of super jacked Rich dudes
cosplaying as like poor hippies
can't do it
okay
update
you are Muslims burning man it's one of
his favorite defense does he go through
yeah oh wait what was the Elon thing
about burning man that we saw that was
so fun funny I wonder how he goes to
burning man dude you are the man yes
there's nobody more than man than you
how can you even show your face there
you should be like murdered but Bear
Hands they should be tearing you apart
and eating your flesh
if they were true to the name you know
what I mean oh yeah oh my gosh this is
so funny all right so somebody
tweeted this I'm currently standing at
Burning Man along with thousands of
others despite the unexpected challenges
some artists managed to put together an
impromptu catwalk show the I'm in the
mud show is a metaphor for trying stuff
and always learning okay so they're
trolling this is an old video from I
forget what fashion oh that's awesome
I think we even talked about on the show
at the time we were like what the
we can see the community note for it
right this is not burning man it's
balenciaga's mud show at Paris Fashion
Week fall of 2022. Elon replies and says
Burning Man is unique in the world hard
to describe how incredible incredible it
is for those that have never been best
art on Earth dude that is so
embarrassing
they replied so true
is so good man
wow that is really surprisingly
embarrassing man
awesome
wow
so if you're a billionaire you should
not be allowed you should be barred from
entering burning man yeah
period
or say if you come here your life will
be in danger
well apparently that's true for
everything you may be the burning man
that's true you will you maybe be burned
in effigy except not you're not an
effigy you're you may be burned
so here's another one
drowning mat update we got three
quarters of an inch of rain travel is
impossible and there's about 70 000
people stranded on a Aaron lake bed but
fortunately burners are badass and
brought all the supplies we need or most
of us we got people who came by bus
camped on the edge of the city they're
in pop-up tents and at risk of getting
hypothermia but we don't need outside
helps together there are people at risk
of getting hypothermia but we don't need
anybody's help what are you speaking for
the people with hypothermia what the
is going on the furniture hold on I
gotta go back is he kidding Papa fencing
at risk of getting hypothermia but we
don't need outside help we're gonna bind
together get radically self-reliant dry
out the furniture and keep the party
going the alternative is to fall into
despair roll over and die and we all
have a choice in how we're going to
handle this so everyone open up your
Sterling satellite so people can
communicate with their families make an
expedition to the edge of the city with
food and water and don't fight anybody
because we're all in this together bury
those negative thoughts and gratitude
for your life because a couple people
didn't make it last night and know that
we're all going to clean up this is
there's people dying of hypothermia on
the edges but we have radically suffered
for life we're certain that wasn't
parody that was so I think that was real
so I mean he's there I mean as
long as that man has his code oh it's
definitely there but I mean I just don't
know if he's making it with drowning man
Updates this is legitimate humanitarian
disaster but we are resilient community
and we'll transcend the mud apocalypse
he said okay let me look at his other
videos this is him we'll see see how his
lips look in the other videos so here he
is here
burning man saved
uh
uh let's see what this one is so burning
man's been saved in probably three
quarters of the city is already out of
here the road's dried up the wooks left
and then we burned the man and had one
last party now all that's left is to
pick up all the movies this guy's
serious and whether this event ever
happens again depends on how well we
cleaned up so we'll probably know in
about two months I can tell looking at
that van
how well do we clean up well there's a
giant van in the middle of the desert so
not good
we're not talking about little scraps of
paper this is like a whole ass
massive van
it looks burnt too did you guys forget
this yeah
yeah he's dead serious Dan I that one
made me think he is serious wouldn't
yeah Burning Man deaths so let's just
imagine we got 70 000 people together
for a week of prime rib and bingo how
many people do you think would crook by
the end of that event there'll be 15
heart attacks eight strokes and two
people choked to death in retrospect two
people died at Burning Man this year
hell we even had a family friend fall
from our corn landed in the ICU but if
cruising around a desert on bikes is
safer than Bingo then I guess we're
doing all right so let's bro what is
wrong why are you such a burning man
simp out of it
dude is yapping it doesn't
happen
this guy's serious I hate to say it yeah
but he is
um
somebody else is very serious this is
unrelated but this is this is actually
breaking news and I I have to bring
drowning Matt go ahead to your attention
here
the
Tucker Carlson here's the proof of life
Tucker Carlson has interviewed the guy
who smoked crack and had sex that's the
best story ever and the interview has
dropped it's like it's 45 or no we'll
have to do that on Friday we have to
because I'm so confused by this like
Obama's not running y'all know he's like
retired I'm so obsessed with this and
then like
like I'm so glad that Tucker had to
liberate himself from fake media so he
could do hard-hitting journalism
who smoked cracked and had sex with a
Barack Obama oh it's so funny I saw a
tweet earlier that was a screenshot of a
DM to Tucker and it said I sucked and
Joe Biden in 2015 and it said now
we wait
oh my God
like he's gotta get sued for this
because he's not with fox now he's just
interviewing yeah I mean uh the the guy
making the accusation someone's got to
get sued for this yeah endless it's not
it's not really defamation to say oh you
had sex with well he's accusing him of
cheating but also he's accusing him of
smoking crack as while being an elected
official that's pretty defamatory well
maybe he just did it once let's see the
receipts maybe he's got picks it's just
another white man planning crazy
of uh Barack hitting a crack pipe yeah
that'd be awesome too Barack Hussein
well I just want the truth to come out
that's all I care I care about the truth
can you imagine like honesty Integrity
uh and responsibility can you imagine
Democrats being like we have a video of
George Bush smoking crack and having
said it's like what police clap
imagine this we have evidence that
George Bush wrongfully murdered like a
million people right nah
not interesting not interesting boring
oh that's exciting to look forward to on
Friday exciting I laughed so hard when I
saw that me too the title is wrong
didn't uh sorry didn't Laura Bush kill a
dude
uh in like a car crash yeah like when
she was like super young yeah I think I
think that I may remember that
Robert Kennedy did too or Bobby Kennedy
Ted that's Ted I was Dan chapaquiddick
era there are good people the Kennedys
my favorite is lobotomizing their sister
for being too sexual absolutely
and obviously you know Jews created you
know covid they did yeah yeah that's a
joke that's a joke that's a joke we're
making fun of them not a true belief of
ours there's even a play called Laura
Bush kill the guy
um it says on the night of November 6
1963 two days after her 17th birthday
Laura Welch ran a stop sign and struck
another car killing its driver the
victim was her close friend and
classmate Michael Dutton Douglas wow
that seem suspicious
this is a comment from a member
regarding this interview Hassan watched
a bunch of stuff about this guy he's
apparently been arrested for scamming
and has warrants out for scamming he's a
huge con man that's epic
yes well so like but like if you so
if you're a journalist and you're and
you're platforming this guy there has to
be because I'm not a journalist I'm I'm
doing neither is Tucker but he is though
he's not
like at this point I think we can
definitively say that
he's the perception of people who watch
his show is that he's a journalist we're
right but we should
we should I'm saying for I'm saying for
the sake of a defamation lawsuit that he
had some professional obligation to vet
this guy more you can't just have any
dumb weird idiot come on and say yeah I
smoked crack and had sex with this guy
like I feel like there's some liability
here for Tucker there's got to be
I don't know I don't know I don't think
I'm like
I don't think we're liable if somebody
comes on our show and says something
crazy I'm not I'm not we don't do news
I'm not a journalist well even when we
talk about them we're just as much as
him at this point no this man posts on
x.com it's not true though it's not true
he records in his like he records in his
uh shed behind his house
well I am getting sued by Ryan Cavanaugh
for some that variety wrote
that's true
I just read the damn title
all right let's watch this one more
video here's the proof of Life Update I
am alive but
all the activities are shut down we all
slept all night with no house music
bumping no yo they slept last night with
no house music bumping what the hell the
travesty dude man it ain't this
ain't Burning Man
you slept last night with no house music
bumping
dude what is this prison serious
everything stopped because of that
it's horrible
hold on this is an important donation
Susanna thank you for the donation she
said I just joined to tell Ethan how
amazing he looks
had to pause the show to read that one
thank you my lady around helping full
power thank you Susanna
our cables out of the ground so they
don't get stuck in the mud and all we're
doing is kitchen and drinking water
that's it
oh yeah another aspect uh the
organization put out a statement after
the rain saying You must conserve your
food and water
because we don't know when you'll be
able to get out of here
you're supposed to burn I don't know
what they're gonna do so I'm alive
we were just joking because we were like
there's probably gonna be hold on we
were joking like there's going to be all
these rumors that 70 000 people are
stranded in the desert I don't know what
happened a lot of food and it turned
into Hunger Games and they're all having
these huge orgy because they're bored
no we're just doing minimum life
activities that's it and I bet you any
money
dude I'm surprised by the average age of
people at this event they're like old
yeah it seems to be yeah hi like 40.
that's been going on for a long time and
the the long timers are all people that
were young in the 90s so yeah
and they're only people probably they
can afford to go to this yeah and
that
I can probably predict
that everybody's gonna get naked and run
through the mud because they're they're
already talking they go man they just
think we're a bunch of hippies having
orgies anyway tonight we're all getting
naked and run through the mud
okay
yeah so I enjoyed that yeah that's good
I'm a hater of course but I do think um
burning man at least what it's become
now is pretty silly right I'm with you
thank you
thanks for backing me up on that
what that said oh wait there's more
burning man's policy on cars 1997
burning man has prohibited Festival goes
from using cars and trucks oh this was
just extra info in case you uh how are
people getting out what's happening next
yeah yeah okay
it was for when you started asking us a
bunch of questions about burning man so
and none of us being burners could not a
burner
no no never been myself got invited
several times when I was younger but
that looks like a good ass I
didn't have a shitload of money so I was
like no I'm good and a week of not
working yeah
good times right there brother also RVs
you know expensive RV like this is
that's rich people only yeah those are
yeah those are hundreds of thousands yes
plus these are like nice nice ass RVs
too
yes indeed
sorry to break it to you guys but y'all
went and became the man
please
the idea of Elon Musk being had a man
burning Effigy is so damn ironic Larry
Page also loves going too Larry Page
it's a lot of social he's the founder of
Google right yeah I think he's the CEO I
don't know if he was the founder no he
is my favorite is one of The Originals I
saw screenshots of um
one of the people that was trapped there
and they were posting about their
experience people figured out that he
was a lawyer who was the lawyer who
argued in favor of nestle in front of
the Supreme Court in the slavery
the guy who got them off the hook for
slavery uh burned the man yeah
Larry Page is worth 114 billion dollars
I bet he had a nice camper
yeah here we go dude who's going to this
oh no no no no no the lawyers
successfully defended Nestle and their
child slavery case dressing and what
could only be described as pedal Corps
to build a mock courtroom in the middle
of desert Beverly encapsulates the
essence of burning man it's a good tweet
the Surfs dude look at this
weirdo did y'all got to stop going to
this
fist bump
fist bump what is that I pedal core is
really on point yeah for real
oh my goodness man
so Larry Page the lawyer who defended
child slavery and Elon Musk yeah
having a good time
this is what it's all about man just let
go
this guy puts Tim Cook the absolute
shame
Sergey is the other founder and Larry no
not Larry who's Larry weird ass looking
dude
Larry
yeah yeah
good for you Larry he was very odd
looking
looks like the rectangular dude he just
he's like yo is that normal bro you got
to get that checked out you seen a
dermatologist about that
is that lupus
yo look how shiny his lips are dude his
eyes are a beautiful Hazel they are
actually look at that well yeah that wow
look at the complexion of that yeah
she's shiny
it's like he almost aged naturally but
then no somehow everything like the
teeth the lips the cancer under his eye
yeah he's puffy he's puffy yeah he's
puffy he's puffy
some pictures he looks more puffy than
others yeah
okay yeah I get that removed though
probably I love you Larry Ellison were
you at Burning Man probably
free free uh
uh
God damn it what do you call the
injections they do
set up
for the people
love him
being told this is actual I just found
out about Larry eddis Ellison
drop to my knees
all right that's it I gotta go guys all
right it's been a fun show it's been
good you know it's been a been Wednesday
so again tomorrow there's no leftovers
not my fault this time it is Wednesday
Hassan's fault yep and so we'll take the
day tomorrow to prepare a banger for
Friday oh it's gonna be a juice yep we
got a lot
um
why is the Oracle guy so rich they just
they really use it that much
what is Oracle
huh I never heard of Oracle I think it's
like runs every software I don't know
it's something crazy it's an Enterprise
software company they do all kinds of
stuff
but yeah it's mostly for like
professional hundred Nations he's worth
116 billion
I think they also that's Burning Man
money a lot of like uh big databases and
stuff
his daughter uh produces movies as well
really yeah oh I'm sure she earned that
uh
yeah any uh any bangers
she did some big movie I forgot what it
was I'm like
sorry Dan if you want to Google that
maybe Zach
wait what is it I try not to go is
Zach's trying to stay what are you
talking about why do you want to explain
what's happening I don't know what the
you're talking about dude I'm
explaining and explain who's actually
winning we took we took some bets at the
beginning of the show how long the
episode was going to be today because
it's been so long since we had one
as well our runtime bets and we and we
did Price is Right rules so if you go
if you go over at all you're out Ian
seriously that was that was there has
been so much uh Ballot Box manipulation
going on they've been dangling things in
front of you we were still able to talk
about burning man it's in the title how
long have we been going three hours 49
minutes and 13. so let's end this I'm
gonna win
316 was right when the food arrived I
almost timed it perfectly it kept going
but we don't and we never end when the
food arrives well I'm bummed out I
obviously did 420 but that's irrelevant
the Mr Beast versus septic eye septic
eye drama seemed pretty interesting oh
you shut the up save some juice for
Friday
why are you saying shut the up Zach
needs it to be longer no no no no see I
win no I win Zach you up you
should have done 359. right rules oh
I thought you were like
the show if the show ended right now I
win oh yeah
listen the show is ending right now I'm
I'm not gonna rip it we're done I win
but Mr bees
okay I didn't think he was rigging it
Friday wait I thought if it goes over
you lose bragging rights I thought if
you go over at all you lose no because
right now no one's winning no that's not
true well how long we've been going
[Music]
three hours fifty minutes
where AB is winning no no I'm winning
no no no no I think it's a b dude yeah
I think that I think they're right I
think we need to go two more minutes
overshot it
now in this case it's run time
you you it was went for 350 and you
guessed 340. you got overblown yeah
it's the your uh okay whatever so hold
on bring that up again
oh so we're just doing the opposite of
that we're just not because it's run
time it's different right you know how
Price is Right rules works I know what
price is right works
so there the person that said four hours
what do you mean what does going over
mean to you then because it doesn't make
sense their prediction is over where it
really landed if we ended right now four
hours is over is more than three hours
and 50 minutes therefore this one over
this is out so you can't so basically
then you're getting stun locked into a
loss right now I think it should be who
yeah I know the more we talk about this
the less likely I am to win
right now I'm winning wait explain this
to me that's pretty close
because what's the difference between
Zacks and Dan's because right now it's
getting pretty close you mean a b
oh yeah a b sorry Zach you blew it but I
thought the two minutes because I
thought I could manipulate you you
wouldn't because I have that power
well you're trying to get the retainer I
do have to go guys I'm sure you don't
want to try it a little little diddy
here
I'm good
yeah
there you go you know let's talk about
it we'll see you guys on Friday thank
you guys
[Music]
[Applause]